Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Pöttlerff und das ist jetzt schon die dreißigste
Ausgabe hier in unserer Serie rund um die Geschehnisse in der Welt und vor allem das was immer gerade so besonders brennt. Ja und was hat gebrannt hier in der letzten Zeit natürlich Corona und auch das hier
ist eine weitere Ausgabe in der Reihe, wo wir hier versuchen, ein bisschen,
Carvaric zu bieten und während ich mich ja mit dem Pavill einmal die Woche
zum Corona Wickly treffe, um hier Zahlen und digitales zu besprechen
Kommt jetzt mal was anderes zwischendurch, denn heute ist äh CWA Day, der Corona One-App, die jetzt auch hier über Wochen und Monate besprochen wurde.
Also
der Versuch hier in irgendeiner Form, dem Contact Tracing, ähm der Verfolgung des Virus, eine digitale Komponente hinzuzufügen. Diese App
die wird jetzt erscheinen in Deutschland und dementsprechend geht auch gerade die Berichterstattung wild rum, alle müssen jetzt irgendwas dazu zu sagen haben, alle versuchen auch irgendwas dazu zu sagen
ich würde sagen, das gelingt äh teilweise und teilweise nicht so sehr. Ich wiederum dachte mir so, hole ich mir mal ein bisschen äh First Hand
Kompetenz hier ins Boot und begrüße gleich zwei Gäste heute, nämlich den Malte, Malte Jan Duda, hallo Malte,
und den Thomas Thomas Klingball hallo. Und ihr seid.
Zwei von einer Miriade von Programmierrand, die äh in den letzten Wochen und Monaten tatsächlich an diesem Projekt mitgefeilt haben.
Stimmt, ne?
Ja. Also Miriade ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu hoch gegriffen, aber wir waren schon ganz nettes Team, ja.
Dann ähm erzählt mir doch vielleicht erstmal äh wer ihr eigentlich so seid, fangen wir doch mal mit dir, malte äh an. Bist du schon immer programmieren unterwegs gewesen oder wie muss man dich einschätz.
Von immer da ist die Frage wann halt immer anfängt also.
Immer setzt und nach zehn Jahren ein.
Ja dann schon immer, allerdings studiert hatte ich Luft und Raumfahrt.
Ähm dann aber vorm Abschluss eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit in der IT gearbeitet und dann irgendwie dabei geblieben,
äh so dass jetzt die Luftfahrt eher so das Hobby ist und ähm Entwicklung Softwareentwicklung halt dann äh zum Beruf geworden ist.
Aber eigentlich wolltest du zum Mond oder ihm.
Ja, also Astronaut war eigentlich dann relativ früh, nicht mehr auf dem Plan, weil das so als Deutscher halt nicht ganz so einfach ist. Also, da war dann eher ähm.
Pilot und äh Testpilot oder äh Ingenieur für Luftfahrt stand dann auf dem Programm.
Rocket Science.
Äh eher Erodynamik, also tatsächlich jetzt nicht so wirklich ähm Raketen ähm bauen, aber halt Flugzeuge.
Eine gute auch Raketenbrochen, Ero Dynamik, so ist ja nicht.
Also auch das, was jetzt grad, was man mit Space Ex halt mitbekommt, es ist natürlich absolut faszinierend und da äh biegt man dann schon etwas zurück und überlegt ab und zu mal, ob man mich doch lieber äh bauen würde.
Aber ich bin schon ganz zufrieden mit dem, was ich jetzt auch jeden Tag mache.
Und was machst du jetzt so?
Letztendlich bin ich jetzt seit August bei SAP. Ähm davor war ich mit einem Start-up unterwegs und davor freiberuflich in der IT tätig und auch als Werkstudent davor,
und bin jetzt ähm vor allem im Bereich Cloudinfrastruktur unterwegs bei der SAP und,
auch ähm ja, maßgeblich mit äh beteiligt an Open Source Projekten im Bereich Cloudinfrastruktur.
Mhm. Und Thomas, wie ist das bei dir? Wollst du auch Raketenwissenschaftler werden?
Nee, also ich habe tatsächlich den Softwareweg relativ frühzeitig eingeschlagen, das heißt ähm mit dem Studium, ich habe gleich IT-Systems Engineering studiert und bin seitdem halt auch dem Softwarefarbtreu geblieben.
Und ich sage mal so, nach der jetzt geltenden Definition von schon immer, äh, kann ich fast behaupten, ich bin schon immer bei der SAP. Also, ich bin jetzt seit fast neun Jahren dabei.
Ja, bin auch immer noch wirklich happy damit. Also, ich bin happy mit der Software, happy mit der SAP.
Und was es da so dein Schwerpunkt.
Mein Schwerpunkt in den letzten Jahren hat sich eigentlich äh massiv in Richtung Fullsdeck entwickelt und eigentlich ein bisschen drüber hinweg. Das heißt, ich mache äh viel,
Tests mit Hardware-Prototypen, baue viel Showcases auf, baue viel äh,
Evaluierungshard war am Ende, um zum Beispiel zu sagen, okay, wir wollen Systeme anbinden, die echte Sensordaten,
in irgendeiner Datenbank rein liefern und ich sitze dann halt an der Stelle auch einfach, dass wir diese Sensoren Prototypen, dass wir einfach mit echten Daten arbeiten.
Mhm. Also meine anderen Worten, ihr seid beide bei SAP fest verdient und auch schon einige Zeit äh dabei.
Und jetzt seid ihr aber in dieses Chorona Warn-App Team hineingeraten. Ähm da sprechen wir dann auch gleich mal ähm drüber, wie es dazu kam. Jetzt,
werdet ihr ja auch frühzeitig mitbekommen haben, dass es so ein Virus äh gibt und wir also so ein bisschen in der Notlage äh befinden.
Was war denn eure erste Wahrnehmung von diesen von dieser ganzen Debatte,
digitalen Mitteln hier in irgendeiner Form ein Beitrag leisten zu können. Also war, habt ihr da auch schon sofort drüber nachgedacht oder wodurch wurde das äh getriggert.
Ja, also ich selbst hatte eigentlich nicht direkt dran gedacht. Also man hat das Ganze ja irgendwie im Dezember, Anfang Januar mitbekommen, dass es halt in China wieder äh so ein Virus gibt. Das hieß ja damals auch,
noch gar nicht Koron Navirus, sondern ich weiß gar nicht mehr, woran Virus oder irgendwie sowas.
Nee, das ist äh nur der Spin, den Trump da gerne ähm haben möchte. Man sprach erst von neuartigen Corona Virus. Das war's dann eigentlich auch erstmal. Das hatte noch keinen Namen, das dauert dann noch ein paar Tage.
Ja, jedenfalls war da ähm noch überhaupt nichts hier irgendwie bei uns zu merken und ähm irgendwann kam's halt rüber. Und interessanterweise, der erste Fall, den es halt in Deutschland gab, ähm es war ein Nachbar von einem Kollegen von mir.
Und da waren natürlich alle dann erstmal wieder nervös und man hat sich erstmal.
Dieser berühmte Münchner äh Cluster.
Ja, genau, also da, ich glaube, weil wir Bastel wo da so war, der und ähm ja, das war ein Nachbar vom Kollegen von mir, mit dem ich halt viel zusammenarbeite und,
der war dann schon etwas nervös. Ähm aber jetzt von App oder so haben wir da noch nicht gesprochen. Also da lief es ja wirklich noch mit der manuellen Nachverfolgung, was ja auch ähm gut funktioniert hatte.
Und,
beim Gier, Persönlichkeim, dieses, diese ganze Äpthematik eigentlich erst später an, als tatsächlich auch in Deutschland schon äh in die Richtung was gemacht wurde. Also, ich bin selbst nicht ähm auf die Idee gekommen, dass man da jetzt eine App bauen sollte.
Ja. Du Thomas, ähnlich.
Ich vermute, ich bin dann sogar noch ein kleines Stück später dazugekommen, thematisch, weil ich halt einfach Situationsbedingt äh viel Zeit,
zwischen meiner normalen Arbeit noch und äh der Familie aufteilen musste, weil die Kinder halt plötzlich zu Hause waren, das heißt die Nachrichten sind oft einfach hinten übergefallen.
Dann kam mir diese ganze Debatte auf mit okay, jetzt machen wir mal eine App,
Wobei, ich glaube, am Anfang gab's noch sehr unterschiedliche Vorschauen darüber, äh was eine App leisten kann. Also,
gibt ja auch im Prinzip mehrere Ansätze. Wir haben schon seit einiger Zeit diese Datenspende-App zum Beispiel, also sie sammeln von Gesundheitsdaten und damit Maschinen-Learning rübergehen und irgendwie versuchen, rauszufühlen, was denn jetzt gerade äh abgeht
so wie man jetzt äh im Abwasser äh den Virus nachweis, um zu schauen, ob eine Stadt belastet ist, äh in irgendeiner Form vielleicht schon mal so die, die Temperatur messen.
Aber dann ging's ja dann relativ schnell los und dann kam ja auch,
bald so diese Frage auf, ja, okay, wie macht man's denn jetzt eigentlich am besten? Wir haben das ja hier bei UKW ausführlich diskutiert und äh debattiert, das Zentrale Modell, Versus eines,
dezentralen Ansatzes, dann ging's ja heiß her, dass äh per PT Projektrahmen hoch, es gab verschiedene Ansätze, die auch aus diesem Virus,
Hackersorten äh hervorgekommen sind, wobei sich eigentlich will
schon relativ früh, so dieses dezentrale Modell so ein bisschen als der Favorit, einer bestimmten äh Klientel,
herausgestellt hat. Also alle, die von vornherein dachten so, hm na okay, da müssen wir uns aber echt mal viel Gedanken über Privatsphäre und Datenschutz machen, haben eigentlich dieses Modell
favorisiert, während ich den Eindruck hatte
dass dieses zentrale Modell für viele vor allem deshalb interessant war, weil es eben so ein Versprechen auch versuchte mitzubringen, so dieses umso mehr Überblick. Wir haben äh umso mehr können wir da EPD meologisch in irgendeiner Form nachführen, et cetera, was ich ja durchaus für ein legitimen,
Anspruch halte, also ist ja für alle eine neue Situation äh gewesen, bis dann,
ja, das Ganze so ein bisschen äh heißer debattiert wurde und natürlich dann auch der Vorstoß von Apple und Google natürlich noch mit dazu kam. Zu welchem,
Zeitpunkt seid ihr dann so damit eingestiegen und dann so Wahrnehmung gehabt, Malte.
Also das Ganze lief eigentlich so, dass ähm per PT schon am Laufen war.
Und ich weiß noch, das war am dritten April, da äh Nacht hatte ich ähm programmiert und ähm lag irgendwie noch im Bett morgens zehn Uhr, zehn Uhr dreißig oder so und bekomme äh Message von einem Kollegen von mir, der hat geschrieben,
hier der Martin jetzt unser arbeitet jetzt an der Corona App. Und ich dachte mir nur so also das ich war froh, dass wir mit der App nichts zu tun hatten, weil wir dann halt auch nix falsch machen können,
und dann hier Kollege von mir, der Martin wollte dann da loslegen. So und ich wusste, okay, wenn der da halt da dran ist, dann dann macht er das halt auch. Und jetzt musst du dich drum kümmern, dass das halt,
nicht irgendwie so ein Quatsch wird. Also ich hatte zuerst gedacht so oh Gott jetzt kommt hier GPS und,
Tracking äh Bewegungsmuster von sämtlichen Leuten und sowas.
Und habe halt dann äh den Kontakt hergestellt, zu der kleinen Gruppe, die es da gab, also wir waren zu dem Zeitpunkt zu dreht oder zu viert.
Da hat man gefragt, hey wie schaut's denn überhaupt aus? Und letztendlich äh wurde die SAP halt gefragt, ob man per PT nicht ein bisschen unterstützen kann.
Einfach mit ähm den Möglichkeiten, die wir als SAP halb haben. Wir hatten kurz zuvor an dieser Rückholer App ähm gearbeitet, also da gab's.
Um die Touristen wieder nach Hause zu holen. Mhm.
Genau. Also das war eine App, die wird von der SAP entwickelt äh innerhalb von vierundzwanzig Stunden oder sowas,
und das war halt das eigentlich nur ein Formular, mit einer Datenbank hinten dran.
Naja gut, aber man muss ja auch erstmal äh zustande kommen.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn die SAP irgendwas machen kann, dann ist es halt ein Formular mit einer Datenbank.
Formular können wir.
So und äh das lief halt gut und letztendlich wurden wir dann halt nochmal gefragt, hey komm mal da nicht nochmal irgendwie helfen. So und dann war klar, okay, es geht halt um,
Das war schon mal recht positiv, dass dieses ganze GPS Thema halt dann raus war, weil auch per PT, die letztendlich dieses äh zentrale ähm Contract Contectracing dann verfolgt haben,
ähm basierte halt auch schon auf Bluetooths. Also auf dem Bluetooth und hat's halt keine Bewegungsmuster jetzt per se erstmal von den Leuten erstellt.
So das war äh schon mal so das erste aufatmen. Aber dann ähm kurze Zeit später hatte der CCC auch seine Prüfsteine ähm herausgegeben,
und es wurde nach und nach klar, dass eigentlich der zentrale Ansatz nicht so unbedingt das ist, was man verfolgen möchte, weil hier einfach aus ähm.
Ja Datensparsack Datensparsamkeitsgründen ähm noch ein bisschen was optimiert werden kann.
Wenn du sagst, es wurde klar, wem wem wurde das klar? Also es wurde ob euch da im Team klar oder du hast es nur in der öffentlichen Diskussion mitverfolgt.
Ja, sowohl als auch. Also ich meine, am Anfang war ja auch in der öffentlichen Debatte vor allem das GPS-Bestand halt nicht so gut da und dieses Bluetooth war ja schon ein Schritt nach vorne.
Und als man sich das dann genauer angeschaut hatte, also sowohl wir als auch die Leute, weil wir in dem Hacker von oder halt auch der CC,
Also wir haben in der Öffentlichkeit ähm dann die Debatte gehabt, ähm zentral, wäre es versus dezentral und hier wurde dann klar, dass wir über das dezentrale System halt weniger Daten sammeln, aber letztendlich das gleiche ähm Ziel erreichen können.
Das gab's in der öffentlichen Debatte, aber halt auch ähm bei uns intern. Also, wir haben uns natürlich auch im Detail halt angeschaut, wie die einzelnen Systeme funktionieren,
sowohl das zentrale ähm System als auch das dezentrale System. Und ähm die Sache ist halt.
Wusste ja keiner, ob das Ding überhaupt funktioniert. So und wenn man dann einen Haufen Daten gesammelt hat,
und am Ende klappt das alles überhaupt nicht. Äh dann hat jeder irgendwie ein bisschen Privatsphäre geopfert, aber hat letztendlich kein Readan. So und wenn wir das Gleiche jetzt erreichen können und dabei weniger Daten sammeln, ähm dann ist das, glaube ich, einfach der richtige Ansatz.
War denn zu dem Zeitpunkt schon klar, dass Google und Apple mit auf dieses Boot draufspringen werden.
Nee, zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht. Also es kam ein bisschen später, ähm wir hatten immer noch ähm den Kontakt auch gesucht zu den,
äh Gruppen aus dem Hacker von und haben mit denen auch kommuniziert, hey äh woran entwickelt ihr, wie baut ihr das auf? Ähm die ganzen Virus-Gruppen haben sich gemerkt zu ITO,
und auf der anderen Seite gab's dann noch das DP drei T, was dann von einigen Universitäten in der Schweiz entwickelt wurde,
und das waren so die beiden Ansätze im dezentralen System letztendlich die halt am Marktbahn.
Mhm. Und mit denen habt ihr dann sozusagen auch schon unmittelbaren Kontakt gehabt zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Genau, also wir haben natürlich mit jedem gesprochen, wir haben mit PT gesprochen, wir haben mit ITO gesprochen, mit DP3 T und haben halt geschaut, okay, welches System ist es denn Wert, wirklich zu verfolgen.
So und ähm wir kamen dann letztendlich relativ früh schon dem zu dem Schluss, ähm dass wir eigentlich das zentrale System nicht unterstützen wollen.
Allerdings ähm lief hier halt auch einfach dieses Projekt schon, was auch von der Bundesregierung unterstützt wurde. Ähm.
Und da wollten wir jetzt nicht sagen, ah, ist ja alles Quatsch. Wir bauen jetzt was Neues. So, also wurden ja gefragt, ob wir unterstützen,
und deswegen haben wir halt geschaut, okay ähm können wir da irgendwie was beitragen und haben uns dann entschieden? Nee, also ein zentrales System wollen wir jetzt gerade nicht äh so wie es ist, unterstützen.
Dann äh wurde die Kritik immer lauter an dem äh Zentralen System. Der CSC hatte die Prüfsteine veröffentlicht, dann kam auch noch Apple und Google hinzu und das ist hier ein sehr zentrale Komponente letztendlich,
Also bei einem zentralen System hatten wir halt immer das Problem oder allgemein hatten wir bei dem Contectracing das Problem,
dass wir eine Unterstützung von Apple brauchen, um halt äh die Applikation auch im Hintergrund laufen zu lassen.
Zumindest auf den iOS Devices, bei Android ist es ja theoretisch möglich.
Genau. Aber konkretes Problem war halt immer Apple. So und äh die haben da halt einfach die Macht über die Apps, die in dem App Store kommen und auch über die API-Zugriffe, die man als App entwickelt bekommt.
Und es hat sich halt herausgestellt, dass ähm Apple und Google einen Alternative ähm erarbeitet hatten, die nach dem dezentralen System funktioniert und die Aussage von Apple und Google war halt auch immer.
Wenn ihr Apps in die App Stores reinbringen wollt, dann musst ihr auf unserem System aufbauen, ansonsten habt ihr nicht die Möglichkeit, halt eure App auch im Background laufen zu lassen. So und,
Das war halt letztendlich auch ein entscheidender Faktor, der letztendlich dazu geführt hat, sich von dem zentralen System abzukehren und ähm diesen dezentralen System anzuzuwenden.
Was war denn deine,
Wahrnehmung, wie Apple und Google da ins Boot gekommen sind. Also soweit ich, es gab ja ein, äh, passiert immer ganz genau äh irgendeiner.
Amerikanischen Tech äh Webseite, so ein Bericht, wie das Projekt so zustande gekommen ist und dann ging's wohl ursprünglich
von Apple aus, die dann relativ schnell sich mit Google zusammengetan haben
Ich freue mich halt immer nur, was hat eigentlich diese Aktivität getriggert? Also, waren das sozusagen überhaupt schon die ganzen Debatten in Deutschland? Man hat ja den Eindruck, dass Deutschland und die Schweiz muss man dazu sagen. Äh hier relativ früh am Ballwaren.
Ja, also es war auf jeden Fall so, dass du dem Zeitpunkt schon auch Kontakt aufgebaut wurde, zu Google und so Apple, um eben genau diese App Store-Thematik zu diskutieren. Und äh hier sind wir halt einfach mit diesem zentralen System an an die beiden Unternehmen rangegangen,
und äh die haben gesagt, nee, also so wollen wir das eigentlich nicht haben und waren deswegen auch ein bisschen im Zugzwang, eine Alternative anzubieten.
Ähm was letztendlich auch wieder den Vorteil hat, wenn es die beiden Unternehmen machen, dass wir halt,
einfach weltweit irgendwie ein bisschen den gleichen Standard auch aufbauen können, weil halt iOS und Android die beiden Plattformen sind, die halt weltweit verteilt sind,
Und wenn jetzt die Firmen, die dahinter stehen, halt auch die Protokolle definieren und umsetzen, dann sind wir alle schon mal einen ganz großen Schritt weiter.
Was du da äh zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon äh dabei Thomas oder dich noch was noch gechillt.
Nee, zu dem Zeitpunkt habe ich einfach noch mein normales Leben gelebt, das heißt, ich habe ganz regulär gearbeitet, das getan, was ich sonst mache, mich um die Kinder gekümmert.
Und äh einfach die ganze Thematik nur in den Medien verfolgt. Ich habe halt schon gemerkt, okay, da kommt jetzt Framework von Apple, Google hoch, habe das halt auch äh immer mal wieder reingeschaut, was es dann neues gibt,
einfach, weil's mich persönlich auch interessiert hat, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt war es halt noch gar nicht Teil meines Arbeitsauftrags.
Das hat sich ja dann äh relativ schnell geändert. Also, die ganze Debatte eskalierte ja dann ein wenig, wurde auch sehr öffentlich geführt. Es gab bei
PT, also ich glaube, der letzten dieser Name war äh ein ein Grund, warum das irgendwie so nichts werden konnte. Wobei DP3 T jetzt auch nicht so sehr viel besser ist.
Also ich habe mal gehört, die haben die Namen sich ausgesucht, damit sie am Ende wirklich nicht benutzt werden in der Öffentlichkeit, damit sie sich jetzt noch keinen Namen ausdenken.
Das hat ja super funktioniert. Jetzt haben wir den Salat. Naja gut. Ähm,
wenn sie zumindest von vornherein die Bindestriche rausgelassen hätten, dann hätte man zumindest bei den Hashtags äh halbwegs Ordnung gehabt. Naja, ähm,
dann kam es, ich sage mal zu so einer Wende, äh die ein bisschen überraschend war, dass die Bundesregierung das offensichtlich.
Ja, so wahrgenommen hat, wie es auch tatsächlich stattgefunden hat, dass es da einfach diese diese Hürde äh gab, dass das äh Apple sich äh da versperrt hat, gesagt hat, okay, wir können da schon was machen, aber nicht so
und ähm wenn ich das richtig sehe, war ja auch DP drei T mit diesem dezentralen Modell im Prinzip auch schon auf dem Markt
hat das gegen dieses zentrale Modell gepitcht und Eppel hat einfach gesagt, ja können wir machen, aber dann machen wir nur das und hat sich eigentlich extrem davon inspirieren lassen und,
Sobald ich das sehe, geht da ja auch kein Blatt dazwischen, also das ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen dieselbe Idee, die eben nicht nur DP3 T gehabt haben, sondern der auch der Dinos-Buchnetz-Politik aus für dich äh vorgetragen hat und was.
Ja auch in diesen Hecke von ähm behandelt wurde. Einfach weil ich denke ist ein bisschen.
Ist ein bisschen leicht gesagt, aber ich denke, wenn man sich so ein wenig mit den Technologien auskennt und sich anschaut, wie diese Systeme sich so verhalten und was die eigentlich so für für Nöte und Zwänge auch haben,
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es unausweichlich, dass man auf dieses Modell kommt, aber es ist dann schon doch irgendwo so, dass man sich das anschaut und sagt, so, ja, so sehr viel andere Methoden,
gäb's jetzt halt eigentlich auch nicht. Also es nahe liegend es vielleicht nicht das richtige Wort, aber es ist so, man schaute sich das so an, dachte sich so, ja, okay, so könnte das vielleicht funktionieren.
Also es läuft letztendlich auf diese Technologie hinaus. Also es gibt halt verschiedene Sachen, die man zur Auswahl hat und am Ende sagt man, ja, das ist eigentlich schon das System, dass wir am liebsten umsetzen würden.
Einfach auch weil's auf möglichst vielen Endgeräten, in der Form auch Umsetzbar ist. Das darf man auch nicht außer Acht lassen, dass halt äh Bluetooth am Ende auch als Technologie mit Sicherheit nicht unumstritten ist, aber halt verfügbar.
Also unumstritten im Sinne von, ob es denn dafür geeignet ist, ne?
Das ist ja ein ganz, ganz heißes Thema. Es wird wurde diskutiert und wird auch immer noch diskutiert,
so zumindest in den Medien, man sieht das bei uns auch aufgeht, hab ja immer wieder hochblubbern, dass immer wieder die Frage kommt, muss es denn wirklich Bluetooth sein, aber halt auf der anderen Seite ist es am Ende jetzt das, was Apple und Google unterstützen und damit auch selbst supporten.
Ja, ist ja auch nicht so, dass jetzt eine große Auswahl an Alternativen gäbe, also diese GPS methode scheitert ja im Prinzip schon dadran, dass dass die Leute zurecht Panisch werden würden, wenn die ganze Zeit ihre Location gedreht wird, auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite
ist es halt auch einfach nicht genau genug und diese Nähe hat sich ja dann letzten Endes auch aus der ganzen Virusforschung herausgestellt, das ist halt eigentlich das Ding, was man messen will und da gibt's nun mal,
dem Bereich derzeit keine andere Technik, die das macht.
Glaube Ultraschall könnte man noch an der Stelle benutzen.
Das ist auch, glaube ich, versucht worden, aber das hat natürlich dann das andere Problem, die letzte, so eine App runter und die sagt dann erstmal, ja, ich möchte jetzt erstmal dein Mikrofon benutzen. Ja. Und es hilft, glaube ich, auch nur äh beschränkt. Also das ähm.
Also eine weitere Technologie, die ja nochmal angesprochen wurde, war ähm die Funkmasten zu benutzen und halt dann die Positionsbestimmung nur über die Netze zu machen und wird das ja noch ungenauer als das GPS. Ähm.
Kommt halt einfach nicht in Frage.
Wie kam es denn dann zu dieser Zuteilung dieses Projektes der Corona Worn-App an SAP und an die Telekom. Also konkret ist das, glaube ich, Tiersystems oder Telekom, also.
Sagen wir einfach mal Telekom, das ist dann weder deutsche Telekom noch Thesistims, sondern.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert bei uns ja am Ende genauso. Ich meine, ob das jetzt bei uns die SAP SE ist, dir Sabt Deutschland. Sind ja auch alle gegliedert.
Okay, also bleiben wir bei Telekom und SAP. Äh warum,
kam es dazu, was was war so das naheliegende. Also wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, gab es ja sowohl bei der Telekom,
als auch bei SAP, jetzt mal ganz unabhängig von dieser Touristenrückholungs äh App schon andere Projekte, die mit den Gesundheitsämtern und den Laboren in irgendeiner Form äh zusammengearbeitet haben.
Genau. Also ähm.
Wir wollten also SAP-Seite, ich wollten wir halt schon immer irgendwie dann die eigene App ähm rausbringen, die nach dem Dezelt dezentralen System funktioniert und haben uns halt angeschaut, okay, was müssten man denn dafür umsetzen? Und ähm zwei Komponenten.
Die halt noch so ein bisschen offen waren, waren die Anbindungen an die Labore,
aber auch ähm die Infrastruktur, die letztendlich auch beim dezentralen System halt auch noch nötig ist. Also auch beim dezentralen System haben wir halt einen Server der Daten verteilt.
Und ähm ja, wir haben uns nicht ganz getraut, diese Infrastruktur zur Verfügung zu stellen für achtzig Millionen Kleins,
ähm wo wir dann wissen, dass die Telekom sowas einfach jeden Tag macht. Also mit Magenta TV oder sowas, die bedienen halt einfach täglich Unmengen an Entgräten ähm.
Und da haben die halt einfach seit Jahren Erfahrung mit.
Wir als SAP haben eher Businessapplikationen und nicht ganz so viele kleinste bedienen müssen. Deswegen war halt das schon mal ein Pluspunkt für die Telekom,
und zudem hatte die Telekom auch schon eine erste Anbindung an die Labore geschrieben. Also da gab's schon mal eine, eine App, die letztendlich die Testergebnisse reportet,
und das passt natürlich dann auch noch mit hinzu. Also so, dass wir dann auf SAP Seite eher die App Entwicklung gemacht haben.
Und die Telekom ist dann zuständig für Cloudinfrastruktur und die Anbindung der ähm Labore.
Und ähm ja Mitte Ende April haben wir dann halt die ähm die Verbindung hergestellt zwischen SAP und Telekom und kamen zu dem Schloss hey, ist eigentlich eine gute Idee, lass uns das mal zusammen jetzt ähm dem Kanzleramt vorstellen.
Und dazu kam's dann.
Genau. Also wie gesagt, das Geschrei war zu dem Zeitpunkt schon relativ groß, also es gab einen großen Widerstand gegen das zentrale Modell,
und ähm ich habe ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass die äh Regierung halt auch einfach noch eine Alternative brauchte. Und die konnten wir halt letztendlich dann anbieten.
Und ich glaube, wir haben den Auftrag dann am sechsundzwanzigsten April oder sowas bekommen.
Genau. Der war's der sechsundzwanzigste April.
Ja, das ist noch gar nicht so lange her.
Tage übern Daumen.
Sieben Wochen.
Ja. Okay. Sechsundzwanzigster Präsident, Sonntag. Okay.
Genau, also das Gespräch war am am Samstag, Samstag, Mittag, Samstagabend und am Sonntag stand dann fest äh dass, ja, wie ihr das jetzt machen soll. Und ich glaube, da hatten wir dann auch das erste Mal Kontakt, Thomas.
Genau, genau so sehe ich das nämlich auch hier in meinem Kalender, den nochmal ganz kurz aufgeblättert habe,
Also ich bin halt am vierundzwanzigsten April in das Projekt reingekommen, eigentlich eher,
informell, weil mich ein Kollege gefragt hatte, kannst du mal kurz über die Schnittstellenbeschreibung von Apple Google drüber schauen? Gib einfach mal dein Bauchgefühl, was das für ein Aufwand ist dagegen zu implementieren, ob das technisch vernünftig klingt,
weil ich eigentlich als mein ursprünglichen Background iOS Mobilentwicklung hatte und in den letzten Jahren viel in Richtung Bluetooth die abgedriftet bin einfach und dann auch noch,
IOS Anwendung mit Bluetooth Lo Energy zwischendurch gebaut hatte.
Perfect Match sozusagen.
Und da halt dann halt so ein bisschen drüber geschaut, dachte mir, Mensch, das klingt ja wirklich nach einer Schnittstelle, mit der wir arbeiten können, habe halt angefangen so ein bisschen einfach nur.
Wirklich rein informell das mal so zu skizzieren, wie das so aussehen würde, die Infrastruktur und ja, dann ging die Dinge plötzlich ganz schnell und das hat sich in unser.
Infrastruktur und Architektur, Dokument,
weiterentwickelt, so als ersten Wurf äh auf dessen Basis wir dann angefangen haben, zu überlegen, wie kann man das wirklich in die Praxis holen, ähm an was müssen wir denken,
was kommt da überhaupt auf uns zu.
Was war denn dein Eindruck? Ich meine, es gab ja zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon gleich viel Diskussion, dann hatten wir ja schon äh über Bluetooth als solches. Taucht denn das überhaupt? Habt ihr denn da auch eigene Tests gefahren?
An dem Stadium äh,
kann ich definitiv sagen, dass ich keine Tests damit gemacht habe. Aber ich habe halt in den letzten Jahren viel auch mit Bluetooth Beakons zur Indoor Ordnung äh ausprobiert, geprototype,
und da war mein Gefühl insgesamt eigentlich schon, dass man da was sehr, sehr solides auf die Beine stellen kann. Von daher, ich hatte ehrlich gesagt, keine Sorgen, dass man da was zum Laufen bekommt,
Klar, man muss sich natürlich ganz ehrlich vor Augen führen, wir werden nicht eine Präzision von zwei bis drei Zentimetern hinbekommen. Wahrscheinlich werden auch
fünfzig Zentimeter in manchen Situationen schwierig umzusetzen sein, aber wenn man da halt einfach von der anderen Seite draufschaut, dass man eigentlich
Nur sicher wissen will, wenn man wirklich dich dran war, das bekommt man schon realisiert. Man kann halt nur nicht sagen, war jemand weit weg,
oder weil dich dran und das Telefon wird gerade verdeckt. Aber man kann definitiv sicher verstellen, wie man wirklich dich dran war.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte ja, dass Fraunhofer Institut auch schon den Test gemacht mit der Bundeswehr,
Also da kennen wir noch aus der Presse, die Bilder, wo die Soldaten halt mit der App rumlaufen. Das war noch ähm aus dem PT Projekt und auch die Erkenntnisse, die halt damals gewonnen wurden, äh laufen jetzt auch in die Implementierung von ähm Apple und Google ein.
Tatsächlich. Aha. Ich hätte ja erwartet, dass äh bei Apple auch schon eine gewisse Kompetenz im Bereich Bluetooth äh vorliegt. Manche machen das ja auch schon eine Weile.
Mit Sicherheit also die Steuern halt auch selbst viel bei,
aber das ist halt, glaube ich, ein Feld, wo man in relativ kurzer Zeit sehr viel sehr solide auf die Beine stellen muss und ich glaube, dass einfach jeder Input äh von vor allem fachlich sehr kompetenten Parteien,
unglaublich relevant, einfach ums gemeinsam besser zu machen.
Und da gibt's auch viel ähm Optimierungsmöglichkeiten. Also je nachdem, wie man halt, dass das Handy an sich trägt oder in der Hand hält oder so, hat es verschiedene Ausstrahlcharakteristiken,
und ähm mit den Sensoren, die halt in so einem Handy drin sind, kann man ja relativ gut erkennen, ob's jetzt gerade in der Tasche steckt oder halt in der Hand gehalten wird,
und äh ich glaube, diese Kombination zwischen Entfernungsmessung und ähm Erkennung in welchem ja, wie das Handy grad gehalten wird.
Da gehe ich einfach davon aus, dass Google oder Apple das bisher dann halt noch nicht gemacht hatte und ähm da konnte dann das Fraunhofer Institut letztendlich was beitragen.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob sie das gemacht haben, weil ich meine, du hast ja auch diese Probleme bei den äh Kopfhörern zum Beispiel, Blutkopfhörer äh ne, Handy in der Tasche, auf einmal reißt die Blutusverbindung ab, et cetera, also sind schon so Aspe
die hier immer eine Rolle äh spielen diesen ganzen Stand, aber es ist konkrete,
und Aussagen darüber treffen, das war sicherlich eine ganz neue eine neue Geschichte. Okay, das heißt am,
Ende April hat sich dann für euch quasi äh der Arbeitsrhythmus etwas geändert.
Ja. Was ist denn dann passiert? Also man hat ja so den Eindruck, dass da ähm doch relativ umfangreiches
Team aufgebaut wurde, beziehungsweise eigentlich mehrere Teams aufgebaut wurden und dass er dann sowohl bei SAP
als auch bei der Telekom, so in so kurzer Zeit, so ein komplexes Team aufzubauen, also wer so ein bisschen mal ein Softwareentwicklung geschnuppert hat, weiß
Also viele Leute zusammenholen, ist jetzt nicht unbedingt immer so der Beschleunigungsfaktor per se,
und ähm dazu kommt natürlich neue Aufgabenfeld, hoher Zeitdruck vor hoher, öffentlicher Erwartungsdruck, der dann auch, glaube ich, relativ schnell klar war, hast du ja schon gesagt, so Gott hoffentlich muss ich jetzt nicht dieses Ding machen und so
da äh würde man sich ja auch nicht wundern, wenn dann erstmal alle begrenzt. Wie habt ihr denn das so wahrgenommen, so in eurem Unternehmen wie,
wieder rekrutiert wurde, wurden da im Prinzip schon fertige Teams einfach nur umgewidmet oder wurde da im Prinzip komplett neu zusammengepflückt, um um einfach auch dieser speziellen Anforderung Herr zu werden.
Nee, also es waren schon einzelne Teams, die existierten, die wurden dann äh zusammengewürfelt, sage ich einfach mal, also es gab ein iOS-Team, Android-Team, Backenteam, äh dann kam halt noch ein paar Architekten mit rein,
die Teams unter sich, kannten sich, glaube ich, nicht unbedingt ähm.
Ihr habt euch jetzt auch erst gerade erst.
Wir sind uns gerade das erste Mal persönlich begegnet.
Aber schon sieben Wochen zusammengearbeitet.
Und,
Ja, ich habe ja seit Anfang April das Projekt begleitet und war überrascht, wie schnell letztendlich diese ganze ähm Übergabe dieses dann funktioniert hatte,
und ich muss sagen, anscheinend hat man hier tatsächlich wirklich die die besten Leute gefunden, die man irgendwie zur Verfügung hatte,
und etwas wirklich außergewöhnlich ist, war letztendlich auch die äh Bereitschaft jedes einzelnen halt beizutragen. Also es war irgendwie keine Frage, ob man ähm,
auch zu einer späten Abendstunde irgendwie nochmal jemanden was fragen kann oder sowas. Also es war ähm.
Ungewohnt. Also normalerweise also es gibt auch solche und solche in der SAP, aber so,
üblich ist halt schon, dass man halt Feierabend hat.
Klar ist ja auch gesund.
Ich glaube ganz ehrlich, auch das ein guter Teil von diesem Arbeitsmodus daher kommt, dass wir eh alle remote arbeiten, dass wir hier alle im Home-Office sitzen und das,
dadurch, dass halt auch viel, viel unbedeutender geworden ist, äh wer sitzt gerade in welchem Bürostandort? Wer gehört zu welchem Team? Weil am Ende redet man ja dann doch nur mit den einzelnen Menschen. Und nicht mit Mitglied von Team X.
Alle waren im selben Internetbüro sozusagen.
Genau, das ist halt am Ende die Sache. Man kann halt Leute quer durch Deutschland oder äh quer über die Welt einfach innerhalb von fünf Minuten zu einem Meeting zusammentrommeln.
Ähm weil's eh keine Rolle spielt, ob man jetzt gerade an der Kaffeemaschine im Büro war oder da noch einen Termin hatte, sondern das lässt sich viel viel einfacher zusammenziehen. Und ich habe persönlich das Gefühl, dass man auch viel weniger darüber nachdenkt äh.
Wie kann man denjenigen jetzt gerade dafür einbinden, gehört er nicht normalerweise zu dem Team,
weil's einfach gefühlt keine Teamgrenzen mehr gibt und was das angeht, am Ende auch in vielen Punkten einfach keine wahrgenommenen Unternehmensgrenzen mehr.
Einmal, äh, weiß ich noch, Sonntagabend hatte unsere Entwicklungsleiter irgendwie ähm Termine geplant für die nächsten Tage und hat halt ein Meeting aufgesetzt, das sollte irgendwie am nächsten Morgen um zehn oder so stattfinden, aber er hat
den Zeitpunkt nicht richtig eingestellt, sodass der sozusagen jetzt in einer Minute anfing. Und auf einmal waren zwanzig Leute in diesem Meeting, nur eher nicht.
Und dann, dann kam halt ein Update, Janni ist morgen früh und dann saßen wir alle da, ja, was soll man jetzt machen? Ja gut, der Gedanke, denke ich, geh mal wieder.
Ich denke, was auch zu so einer Motivation erheblich äh hat beitragen können, war ja dieses, diese generelle Bedrohungssituation ist betraf ja auf einmal irgendwie alle,
Ne, es ist ja jetzt nicht so Kunde droht mit Auftrag, auch kein Bock irgendwie äh viel zu langweilig will ich nicht dran arbeiten, ruf mich Motor nochmal an, sondern es man wusste ja
Okay, das, das ist etwas, das betrifft jeden von uns, du hast ja schon gesagt, Kinder zu Hause, et cetera auf einmal ändert sich äh sehr viel, wenn dich sogar alles für manche.
Das äh mag sicherlich auch geholfen haben an der Stelle, oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und also ich wohne allein. Ich habe halt auch nicht viel anderes zu tun. Aktuell. Also, was soll man machen, programmiert man halt eine Corona-App.
Kann man machen, ja.
Kann man aber mal machen. So ähm,
Das war ja dann so ein bisschen wahrscheinlich auch arbeiten oder Vertrag, weil äh so schnell wie das jetzt äh abging, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass der ganze äh Vertragslauf schon komplett abgeschlossen war, aber das war dann sozusagen einfach so ein Handshake, ohne Handshake wahrscheinlich ähm
Projekt.
Ich glaube, der Vertrag hat vier Wochen gedauert, irgendwie sowas. So, um den Dreh, vielleicht waren's fünf Wochen, aber ähm ja.
Ist der Luxus des Entwicklers, dass man darüber gar nicht nachdenken muss.
Stimmt, das betrifft euch natürlich nur sekundär.
Aber auch äh Vertrag nach vier Wochen. Es war, glaube ich, auch Rekord für unser, unsere Rechtsabteilung. Also, die lassen sich dann normalerweise dann doch ein, zwei Wochen mehr Zeit.
Aber ich glaube, das ist genau der Punkt, äh der an vielen Ecken zu finden war, dieses normalerweise dauert das schon noch ein bisschen länger,
Also ich habe jetzt gerade nochmal ein bisschen weiter darüber nachgedacht. Wir haben ja dieses Wochenende äh gehabt und am sechsundzwanzigsten an dem Sonntag wurde dann der Auftrag gegeben und,
Tatsächlich das erste was wir hatten, um mal diese ganze Security-Thematik schon zu beleuchten,
hat wirklich direkt in der Woche darauf angefangen und zwar nicht irgendwann so gegen Ende der Woche,
sondern wir hatten am siebenundzwanzigsten am Montag um zehn den ersten Architekturworkshop zu dem Projekt an sich und am siebenundzwanzigsten um fünfzehn Uhr begann schon das
wo wir halt einfach auch schon gesagt haben, okay, in dem Projekt ist wirklich Privacy First Security First, das heißt, am ersten Tag der Entwicklung,
wird gleich auch über Sicherheitsaspekte hart diskutiert.
Mhm. Und wurde auch.
Wurde auch und ähm ich persönlich habe das von Anfang an begrüßt und das haben viele halt auch wirklich,
sich zu Herzen genommen, das heißt äh am Anfang ist es immer noch so ein bisschen
dass man ja schon sagt, hm, ah, das macht's jetzt aber schwerer für uns, wer da dran denken müssen, was auch interessant zu sehen, wie wir nach diesen fünfzig Tagen ein Projekt halt gefühlt, kollektiv in diesem,
Security und Privacy Gedanken so tief angekommen sind, äh dass schon alle nervös zusammenzucken, wenn sie nur das Wort anonym hören, weil das jetzt so fest tief sitzt äh
dass wir alle wissen, das ist natürlich nur Pseudonym. Das ist, ist witzig, das zu beobachten.
Aber auch die Security war auch ein Grund äh den dezentralen Ansatz zu verfolgen, weil beim dezentralen Ansatz haben wir auf den Servern keine geheimen Informationen,
Also ähm anders als beim zentralen Ansatz, wo man halt drauf aufpassen muss, die Daten zu äh ja zu behalten, damit halt keine ähm Kontaktanalysen äh.
Elf öffentlich geführt werden können. Und ich habe halt gesagt, hey zentral wollen wir gar nicht machen, weil wir sind das größte Hackerziel letztendlich, was es dann überhaupt in Deutschland gib.
Die App des Jahres.
Genau, das muss man erstmal absichern, alles und das andere selbst wenn wir sozusagen gehackt werden, ähm.
Der der Angreifer gewinnt dabei nichts. Also er gewinnt keine Informationen, die er vorher nicht gehabt hätte.
Zumindest nichts, was irgendwie ein besonderen Wert hätte.
Genau, also es geht keine Privatsphäre verloren, sollte unser System aufgemacht werden.
Also das kann er sich auch bequemer einfach so runterladen, ohne Hecken.
Genau. Also er, er wird zwar ein paar Tanz ergaunern, aber dann können wir einfach sagen, okay, Invalidiert und ähm ja, alles wieder gut
aber es gehen keine, also es ist kein Data-League letztendlich, den man ja aktuell immer mal wieder irgendwo bei irgendwelchen Plattformen halt beobachten kann. Das ist hier einfach nicht möglich, weil wir haben keine Daten, die gelegt werden könnten.
Und vor allem wir haben keine Daten, die auch über lange Zeit gespeichert werden,
Das heißt, äh so ein Aspekt, den wir relativ früh und schon angeschaut haben und uns Herzen genommen haben, ist, dass es halt ein Self, das sein soll am Ende. Das heißt, wenn
das System für Zeit N, also sagen wir zwei Wochen, drei Wochen, von keinem Menschen genutzt wird,
wenn er einfach Server mit Lerndatenbanken, die leere Dateien ausliefern an die Kleins, weil einfach nichts mehr da ist.
Wirkte dann so doch schon sehr, sehr charmant dieser Ansatz.
Das heißt.
Wir sind jetzt im Prinzip ja schon an dem Punkt angekommen, wo äh die große Frage war, welche Systemeichitur müssen wir denn jetzt eigentlich wählen? Und das,
dieses API, das sagenumwobene von äh Apple und Google, das hat ja im Prinzip nur die Realität auf den Smartphones festgeschrieben. Hat gesagt, so wird hier irgendwie Protokoll
äh betrieben das und das geht jetzt hier über den Bluetooth-Elter und so und so kann man darauf zugreifen und so diese diese App
sagen, also dieses Wort ist ja so aufgebläht worden in diesem ganzen äh Zusammenhang, ja. Diese App ist ja eigentlich nur so ein, so ein kleines äh Ding auf dem Telefon, was ja,
Schlüssel rein wirft, guckt, ob irgendwelche Ergebnisse gibt und die
dann äh ausliefert. Das heißt, die eigentliche Arbeit ist ja, dass dahinter und ich glaube, das wurde am Anfang auch in der ganzen Debatte etwas übersehen, dass die Komplexität eben nicht auf dem Telefon ist, sondern dass die Komplexität ja eigentlich eher ist
wie binden wir uns denn jetzt eigentlich mit dem Gesundheitssystem dieses Staates an, damit das auch sinnvoller Ergebnisse erzeugt, denn die,
eigentlich archivisferse, die einzige, die es gibt, ist ja dieses, man will verhindern, dass nicht irgendwelche Leute falschmeldung von infizierten, in das System einspielen, weil das dann eben zu Warnungen führen würde, die,
nicht gerechtfertigt sind, sprich hier muss man sehr sicherstellen, dass man ähm.
Sich quasi bestätigung und Informationen aus den richtigen Quellen holt. Und hier kommt dann eben diese ganze Frage auf, wie wie Design man dieses System,
da musste er dann wahrscheinlich erstmal viel gesprochen werden mit Gesundheitsämtern, mit Laboren.
Mit dem RKI, was habt ihr da beobachtet, wie da die Kommunikation gelaufen ist, welche, welche anderen Partner waren sozusagen drumherum noch mit eingebunden.
Glaube, das war halt gerade schon ziemlich gute Aufzählung an der Stelle, weil,
klar, man muss erstmal die aktuellen Prozesse verstehen, wie das momentan abläuft, weil diese ganze Kontakt nach Verfolgung ist der jetzt keine Neuerfindung äh seit der Korona Warn-App,
sondern das existiert ja schon vorher. Das heißt, ich habe halt im Laufe von dem Projekt dann auch über den Paragrafen neun, vom Infektionsschutzgesetz gehört und äh denen kennengelernt,
der am Ende einfach besagt, dass zum Beispiel diese ganzen persönlichen Daten, der äh Kontaktperson,
dann auch übertragen, werden anders oder übermittelt werden mit anders Gesundheitsamt, im Falle eines,
positiven Tests. Das heißt, äh wenn das Labor jetzt feststellt, dass jemand positiv getestet wurde, sind die sogar in der Pflicht, die Daten der Person weiterzugeben, ans Gesundheitsamt, damit dann damit weitergearbeitet werden kann,
und äh das Gesundheitsamt braucht dann halt einfach nur Zeit, um damit arbeiten zu können,
und das war dann halt der Aspekt, wo er gesagt haben, okay, an der Stelle können wir ja am Ende auch ansetzen. Wir können's nur schneller machen, mit dieser Kontaktnachverfolgung, über die App.
Da war dann aber auch der Gedanke gut, okay, irgendwie müssen wir diesen positiven Test ja mit reinbringen. Und da gab's halt die Gespräche mit äh Tiersystems, die halt die Laborthematik schon deutlich besser kennen, als wir einfach, weil das ihr Gebiet ist an der Stelle.
Sie haben jetzt auch nicht vor zwei Monaten angefangen, sondern die waren ohnehin schon in diesem Bereich unterwe.
Genau, die waren schon im Bereich unterwegs, die kannten das Thema halt schon ähm da gibt's halt auch entsprechende Abteilungen, die im Gesundheitsbereich halt auch arbeiten. Und da haben wir uns dann gegenseitig wirklich in,
intensiven Sessions sehr schnell auf den aktuellen Stand gebracht. Haben wir halt am Ende geschaut, okay,
Es gibt dieses digitale Laborverfahren schon, dann müssen wir es jetzt also in die App einbinden, da kann halt die Frage auf äh welche Daten bekommen wir dann,
das war dann ja in dieser QR-Code, der die Information enthält.
Und dann war die nächste Frage, wie können wir das so vernünftig bauen, dass wenn man diesen benutzt
um den Test zu verifizieren am Ende, um das positive Testergebnis bestätigen zu können. Wie machen wir das, dass die Identität des Nutzers an der Stelle nicht preisgegeben werden kann? Selbst wenn.
Man nur mit allen möglichen Mitteln äh das forcieren will,
das heißt am Ende, was wir ja dann selbst auch gemacht haben, ist uns selbst die Böswilligkeit zu unterstellen, dass wir versuchen, können wollten,
das dann zu durchdringen und am Ende dann eine Architektur zu entwerfen, die es uns selbst unmöglich machen würde, das nachzuverfolgen,
und äh das führt dann am Ende zum Beispiel zu so Konstrukten, die auf den ersten Blick werden von oben drauf schaut, leicht krude wirken, wie dann irgendwie,
der Server gibt es toten an denen, der gibt's weiter an den kleinen, der klein, macht nochmal dies und jenes gibt zurück, hinher und äh vermittet das dann mit zu dem Server und der virifiziert ist wieder gegen den,
aber das ist halt einfach nur mit diesem Gedanken in der Hinterhand, dass man halt zum Beispiel nie dieses diese Daten aus dem QA-Code zusammen mit dem.
Kann oder mit dieser Tannen äh in einer Tabelle speichern will, einfach nur um halt diese rückverfolgbarkeit nicht mehr zu ermöglichen.
Man nimmt sich ja auch selber dann auch automatisch ein bisschen aus der Schusslinie. Also in diesem Becken, das kann man ja vielleicht nochmal kurz sagen, gibt's ja so eine zwei große Komponenten, es gibt so den
Corona waren Appserver, also der eigentlich diese ganze Schlüsselverteilung macht und dass das Ziel ist, wenn man von seiner App
quasi meldet hier, ich bin infiziert, um das dann eben anderen melden zu können. Und die zweite große Komponente und das hat dann, wenn ich's richtig verstehe, im Wesentlichen die Telekom entwickelt, dass es dieser Server, der sich also eigentlich,
primär an diese ganzen Labore wendet. Also diesen Test
diese Testzustellung macht. Weil ich das von Anfang an klar, dass dieses übermitteln von Testergebnissen auf Telefon, Teil der App sein sollte.
Wir wussten halt äh von Anfang an, dass es die Testübermittlung auf das Telefon geben wird.
Ein Punkt, der halt an der Stelle auch einfach nicht feststand, der diskutiert wurde ist, muss man jetzt die Testergebnisse von einer App an die andere App übergeben, muss man äh dann ganzes Infra,
Struktur äh System aufbauen oder integriert man das dann halt am Ende doch in eine App.
Und die Entscheidung, dass dann eine App zu integrieren ist, dadurch gefallen, das hat gesagt, wurde für den Benutzer, ist das aus Sicht halt viel, viel.
Ansprechender man gibt dem User viel weniger Hürden dann halt von App zu App springen zu müssen,
und kann damit halt hoffentlich äh die Anzahl derjenigen, die wirklich ihre Testergebnisse auch nutzen, um dann ihre Schlüssel hochzuladen, optimieren.
Es ist halt auch ein bisschen äh ein Missbrauchsschutz. Also wir wollen keine App bauen, wo jeder einfach sagen kann, ich bin infiziert und alle mit denen ich jetzt Kontakt hatte, sollen jetzt mal bitte in Quarantäne gehen,
Das soll eigentlich äh durch eine verifizierung verhindert werden und zwar eine Verifizierung, dass tatsächlich ein Testergebnis für diese Person vorliegt,
und ähm wenn dem so ist und das halt positiv ähm ist, dann darf auch erst der Upload der Kies stattfinden und die Kontakte dürfen gewarnt werden.
Dieses äh digitale Laborverfahren, was du erwähnt hast, Thomas. Ähm das ist etwas, das.
Gab war schon in Place, also das das existierte bereits, also es gab schon eine
Digitalisierung der Rückmeldung von Labor Ergebnis, ein ganz unabhängiges von von der Gruppe neunzehn Problematik also was existierte da was ist da der der Prozess und was was wollte man damit eigentlich bezwecken.
Also diese digitale Rückübermittlung von Laborergebnissen ist ja auch wieder in mehrere Teile geteilt. Zum einen gibt's das natürlich zum Arzt zurück, damit der halt das Laborergebnis nicht per Post bekommt,
sondern halt elektronisch und jetzt aber neuartig an der Stelle ist, dass man halt auch den Patienten schnell über das Ergebnis informieren möchte.
Das heißt, eigentlich war es sozusagen dafür gedacht, um Laborergebnisse an Ärzte oder also wer auch immer mit dem Patienten im äh Verbindung steht, Krankenhäuser, et cetera zu übermitteln, damit das schnell wieder zurückkommt.
Genau, also ich habe mir, habe mich dann noch ein bisschen in Laborinformationssysteme eingelesen, habe gelernt, dass das auch genau so ein Bereich ist, wie zum Beispiel ERP-Systeme, gibt's halt auch die LES-Systeme und ähm.
Dieses was wir als SAP.
Wir so Geld machen.
Ah, Versteher. Okay.
Ganz schnell die Erkenntnis, das gibt schon und das ist aber eigentlich weniger, ich sag mal, dass es hauptsächlich so eher so äh B2B, wenn man das im medizinischen Bereich so sagen kann, also Arztlabor und.
Ich sage mal Funktionsträger zu Funktionsträger.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eher das richtige an der Stelle. Und jetzt muss aber plötzlich der Patient auch informiert werden, weil wenn der Test,
positiv ausgefallen ist, dann möchte man eigentlich gar keine Zeit mehr verlieren, weil dann soll derjenige nicht noch äh kurz einkaufen gehen oder noch die Familie besuchen am nächsten Tag, sondern will man eigentlich,
Minuten gleich sagen, so, jetzt am besten zu Hause bleiben, keinen Kontakt mehr. Ähm.
Und genau deswegen möchte man das dann halt elektronisch übermitteln. Und das Verfahren gab's ja schon, auch vorher.
Das äh wurde im Laufe des Jahres halt auch schon auf die Beine gestellt und auch schon ausgerollt in der ersten Version,
und dann ging's natürlich darum, dass halt auch wirklich bei uns mit einzubinden.
Also das war eigentlich eher Zufall, dass das äh gerade auch sein Reifegrad bekommen hat oder ist das schon länger im Betrieb gewesen?
Weiß gar nicht genau, was da die Timeline war, das ist halt auch so, wenn man selbst nicht betroffen ist, hat man das gar nicht so auf dem Schirm.
Ja, okay, gut, aber war zumindest so, dass das jetzt in der Technologie war, auf dem man zurückgreifen konnte, eine Entwicklung, das heißt, diese ganze Idee mit ein Test hat eine ID
Und mit dieser ID kann man über dieses Laborinformationssystem dessen Ergebnis abfragen, wenn es denn vorliegt, das war sozusagen schon da
Und das, was jetzt im Rahmen dieser äh Chorona Worn-App noch hinzugefügt wurde, war einfach nur, dass in diese ganze App Infrastruktur mit einzubetten, einen äh speziellen Server,
zu machen, der das eben für dieses System mit Abfrag, sodass man das dann eben auch an den Patienten übermitteln kann. Und in dem Fall eben den getesteten
anstatt eben nur in Anführungsstrichen nur die anderen Funktionsträger des Gesundheitssystems vom Ergebnis dieses Tests zu benachrichtigen.
Ja, das stimmt. Das war in der Tat dann an der Stelle komfortabel. Das halt die Vorarbeit schon gemacht wurde, weil einfach dieser zusätzliche Identifer ja auch noch eingeführt werden musste.
Okay, aber dann ist zumindest dieser ganze identifire Geschichte, ist auch nichts, was ihr erst noch erfinden musstet. Das ist natürlich auch ein äh
ein Vorteil, da war ich mir auch nicht so ganz klar, wie denn das jetzt eigentlich so ist.
Vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz zu, wir so wie das Projekt sich an sich aufgestellt hat. Also ihr habt halt
die ganzen äh Teams lokalisiert. Das war ja dann auch relativ klar, was man da so braucht. Man braucht halt Leute, die dieses Back-End machen. Man braucht Leute, die äh die Apps machen, da fallen ja dann eben auch diese ganzen Nebenkriegsschautplätze ab Designer werden gebraucht, User
Experience muss da äh entwickelt äh werden. Gestaltung muss gemacht werden. Die ganze Abläufe müssen getestet werden
und ich denke auch so sagt wie war glaube ich auch von vornherein fester Bestandteil dieses der Planung richtig?
Das war ganz, ganz massiv von Anfang an mit eingeplant. Einfach, weil halt sowas auch unseren Produktstandards genügen muss und exacibility ist einfach ein fester Bestandteil von unserem.
Also mit anderen Worten, das bedeutet so, die App ist auch für Blinde benutzbar, et cetera, all diese ganzen.
Genau, nicht nur vollständig blind, sondern halt auch Fahrblendheit. Also es wird halt schon drauf geachtet, dass die App auch möglichst ohne Einschränkungen screen wieder benutzbar ist und wurde halt dann auch entsprechend getestet dahingehend.
Und jetzt gab's ja natürlich nochmal eine neue Komponente, weil es wurde ja nicht nur die App gefordert,
So, was halt Teil der öffentlichen Diskussion von Anfang an war, zumindest fast jetzt auch die Prüfsteine, dieses CC äh betrifft und generell war es ja auch, glaube ich, die Position der Leute, die sich äh von der Wissenschaft her dort von Anfang an eingebracht haben, dass man sagt,
wäre schon echt gut, wenn das alles Open Source wäre, weil dann lässt sich dieser ganze äh Misstrauensblock noch weiter absenken und äh nebenbei würde man eben vielleicht auch mal eine ganz andere Entwicklungskultur machen,
welche Bedeutung hatte den Open Source, Development bei euch bis dahin.
Also bei mir persönlich hat Open Soß eigentlich eine recht große Bedeutung. Die Projekte, in denen ich äh bisher tätig war, sind alle Open Source,
Und ich meine bei der SAP schaut's halt so aus. Wir haben das eher P System, das ist unsere Cash-Kau und,
Dann gibt es viele kleine Softwaremodule, die man halt braucht oder die auch der Kunde braucht, um mit unserer Software zu arbeiten,
und da spricht eigentlich nicht viel dagegen diese kleinen Komponenten auch zu stellen. Und das macht die SAP halt grad auch, um ja dem Kunden einfach noch ein besseres zu geben,
und von daher ist absolut nichts Neues bei uns.
Also, nicht nur, dass ihr oben sollt benutzt, sondern dass ihr auch selber eigene Komponenten entwickelt und sie auch selber Open saust. Ja.
Also das fängt an bei Frontends, äh bei Styles ähm das geht über ähm,
ja Cloudinfrastrukturkomponenten und endet irgendwo, was weiß ich, also ich kenne auch alle Komponenten gar nicht.
Und und liegen die nur im Netz oder ist es auch schon soweit kulturell, dass sich daraus vielleicht sogar schon eigene Open Source-Projekte mit ihrem eigenen Leben entwickelt haben?
Also ich glaube, jetzt so ein richtiges Projekt, wie Kubernetis oder ähm Doccer oder sowas. Das haben wir jetzt noch nicht irgendwie initiiert. Ähm was wir allerdings machen, ist das für uns in solchen Projekten halt auch selber engagieren,
Also wir sind auch contribluter für große ähm ja, Open Force-Projekt,
aber wir haben es jetzt noch nicht geschafft, dass wirklich jetzt äh ich sage jetzt mal ähm hier ähm eine einem von von SAP entwickelt wurde und dann jetzt groß irgendwie in der das Community genutzt wird.
Ich denke an der Stelle könntest du halt immerhin anführen. Ähm das ist halt SAP's Open Source äh Frontend Library, die halt auf Enterprise Bedürfnisse zugeschnitten ist und die ist halt auch Opens Haus verfügbar.
Ich wollte jetzt auch gar nicht sagen, dass dass jetzt äh Open Source nur dann Open Source ist, wenn man sozusagen auch sofort äh durchschlagenden Erfolg hat und große Communitys heranzieht. Ich meine, das ist ja äh.
Noch vor nicht so langer Zeit.
War ja für große Unternehmen, dieser Gedanke, den eigenen Code ins Netz zu stellen, war ja vollkommen unvorstellbar. Und dann kann das ja jeder sehen und dann äh,
alte ganzen Ängste, die damit verbunden waren. Und ich habe zu den Eindruck, dass ich das dann doch schon sehr gewandelt hat in der letzten Zeit.
Also es gab's auf jeden Fall bei der SAP. Also ich kenn's ja noch von früher, als ich ähm wegstellend war oder halt dann auch freiberuflich gearbeitet hatte. Äh es gab schon wirklich vorbehalte, letztendlich gegen Open Source,
und teilweise sehen wir das jetzt immer noch. Also ähm,
gerade auch wenn wir jetzt über solche Projekte sprechen, wie wir jetzt gerade haben, also ähm ein Projekt, was für die Bundesregierung entwickelt wird, äh für die Öffentlichkeit letztendlich, ähm dass sowas dann Open Source entwickelt wird.
Das das ist immer noch ein Diskussionsthema letztendlich auch innerhalb der SAP, ob man äh ja, also Leute glauben halt einfach nicht, dass man so Geld verdienen kann oder überhaupt irgendwie äh ein nachhaltiges Geschäft irgendwie aufbauen kann.
Aber es scheint trotzdem zu funktionieren.
Ja, sieht man ja. Also da sind auch intern bei der SAP immer noch ein paar Kämpfe zu führen,
also die die SAP ist kein kein Gleichmäßiges, gebildet, sondern es mit hunderttausend Mitarbeitern gibt's dann natürlich auch viele Meinungen. Und
wirklich dieser diese äh Corporate Strategie, die die wandelt sich halt auch jetzt langsam ein bisschen.
Hat da dieses Projekt jetzt auch dazu beigetragen schon.
Also, wir können's jetzt natürlich noch nicht ähm messen, irgendwie, wie es jetzt äh äh was bei rumgekommen ist, jetzt intern, was die Strategie angeht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr starkes Argument für Open Source.
In
dem Moment, wo man sagt, okay, wir machen wir auch open, sonst muss man ja auch ein paar Entscheidungen fällen äh unter anderem so die Lizenz, die gewählt wurde, ist ja eine relativ liberale Lizenz, ist eine immer die Lizenz, wenn ich das richtig in die Apacel,
genau Apacelizenz. Also letzten Endes äh für die Leute, die sich mit Lizenzen nicht so gut auskennen, gibt's da so
sagen wir mal so einen wesentlichen so zwei große Gruppen von von freien Lizenzen, die eine äh die darauf bedacht ist, freie Software auch auf Ewigkeiten freizuhalten. So GPL und äh solche äh Sachen politisch motiviert, hat auch alles seine
Begründung und dann die andere äh Welt eben diese MIT, Lizenzwelt, die sagt so, ja, macht auch was ihr wollt.
Ne, kann jeder benutzen, egal, ob auch kommerziell oder nicht, Hauptsache, ihr schreibt drauf, wer es ursprünglich mal geschrieben habt und äh das war's dann eigentlich im Wesentlichen. Dafür habt ihr euch entschieden, warum.
Also erstmal ist so diese Standard SAP Opens aus Lizenz. Also wenn man sich das aussuchen kann bei der SAP ist eigentlich immer erst die Empfehlung, okay, nimmt eine Patchelizenz,
ähm allgemein haben, große Unternehmen immer ein bisschen vorbehalten gegenüber äh GPL. Hintergrund ist der, dass die GPL halt.
Wie halt sie ist, man kann sagen, sie ist freier, aber auch gleichzeitig unfreier als die Appachi. Weil die GPL gibt halt ein paar Vorgaben,
Also ähm du kannst keine Anpassung an der Software machen,
und ähm die dann nicht zurückkomme. Also du bist verpflichtet, jede Änderung, die du machst, letztendlich auch wieder offen zu legen. Ähm,
Ich glaube, dass das jetzt hier bei der Corona Warn-App gar nicht so ein Problem gewesen wäre. Aber prinzipiell,
ist eigentlich die Epage Lizenz eher so, wir haben hier haste Software mach halt was damit. So und damit kann halt auch jeder arbeiten. Und äh,
es gibt halt auch bei anderen großen Unternehmen einfach ähm ich sage mal, die Regel benutzt keinen GPL.
Und dementsprechend haben wir gesagt, okay, dann nehmen wir eher Patchy, damit schließen wir nämlich erstmal kein Unternehmen aus, was dann irgendwie mitarbeiten möchte.
Und ist die ganze Art und Weise, wie die sich das Projekt dann online ausgerollt hat, auch so der typische äh Weg, wie ihr es immer macht, also Dokumentation war ja
relativ früh da, relativ ausführlich auch in,
sag mal internetkompatiblen Formaten, man äh hat da jetzt nicht irgendwelche Wordfiles runterladen müssen oder äh PowerPoint, Präsentationen vorgelegt bekommen
ähm es gab einen Code of Canda gleich vom Start weg, also was war davon jetzt Standard und was ist vielleicht auch erst im Rahmen dieses Projektes entstanden?
Also wir haben in der SAP ein Open Source Office und ähm die machen jetzt bei uns ganz viel in Richtung Community Management und von denen haben wir halt auch,
ich sag mal, das Raunenwerk für dieses Open Source Projekt bekommen. Also E-Show-Templates oder auch den das ist alles nichts Neues, es konnte mal wieder verwenden,
ähm die die Dokumente, das war schon eine Diskussion. Also ich weiß noch ganz genau, da flogen erstmal die ganzen Worddokumente hin und her und äh.
Äh bin ich, ich habe halt gesagt, hey, macht euch die Arbeit doch nicht doppelt, wir wollen das nachher als Marktdauern haben.
Wir wollen auch Pulreque auf die Dokumente haben. So und äh,
beim World Dokument soll's ja dann nicht bleiben. Es wird dann immer gesagt, ja, da machen wir eine PDF draus. Und es ist ja noch furchtbarer. So und das war äh echt ein Kampf äh über einige Wochen letztendlich dann auch die Kollegen davon zu überzeugen, hier einmal bitte Marktaun.
Weil ich glaube, was jetzt neu war, ist, wo wir gerade so,
über Opposition, wie er das bisher so gehalten hat, es ist halt nicht nur die Bereitstellung von Code, sondern es war ja auch die
zur Schaustellung der Entwicklung und auch die Einladung, an eine Community hier in irgendeiner Form
teilzunehmen. Ich denke, die Erwartungen, wie viel er zurückkam, dürften nicht zu hoch gewesen sein, aber äh ist ja auch nicht so, dass jetzt nichts gewesen wäre.
Ja, es war auch so ein bisschen ein Learning aus dem Pep PT. Also ähm, da gab's ein paar Sachen, die halt nicht ganz so gut gelaufen sind. Erstmal war die Qualität der Dokumentation nicht ganz so gut,
und zum anderen hatte die Community ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass sie halt einfach äh fertigen Code letztendlich äh da das da fertiger Code übern Zaun geschmissen wird,
und das wollten wir halt von vorne rein vermeiden. Und deswegen war halt die Maxime letztendlich in der Öffentlichkeit auch zu entwickeln. Also das haben wir jetzt,
zu einem großen Teil auch umsetzen können,
Es gibt immer noch ein paar Sachen, also ein paar Ishus zum Beispiel, sind nicht oft, sondern werden intern gepflegt. Ja, aber es ist irgendwo, hat man halt immer Verbesserungspotential,
Generell glaube ich haben wir eigentlich ein ganz gutes Open Fast Projekt aufgestellt.
Und ich glaube, man muss an der Stelle auch sagen, es gibt keine geheimen internen gespiegelt, nur äh die manchmal dann über Nacht,
in das öffentliche gesüngt werden, sondern dass was in das öffentliche Postorice Committe wird, ist doch dann wirklich Live Committed. Und also mir sind zumindest auch keine anderen internen Reporters bekannt.
Genau, also war auch im Gespräch, ah nee, wir entwickeln intern, offen internes, geht,
und dann gibt's einmal in der Nacht irgendwie einen Job, der ähm Committe dann alles nochmal auf auf das externe Git hab, mit einem extra Namen, dass man die Entwickler auch nicht sieht oder sowas.
Aber das macht's halt auch schwieriger dann für Pulrigwest und so. Und deswegen war letztendlich ähm bei fast allen Projekten, die wir dort hatten bei allen Reportitoris, einfach nur am Ende,
Switch von Private auf Public und dann war halt das Ding offen.
Und vielleicht den Leuten, die äh mit den ganzen äh Entwickler äh Sprecher an der Stelle nicht ganz so verheiratet sind, eine Brücke äh zu bauen, also
sozusagen was melden von von Fehlern oder Anmerkungen, die man hat, ist sozusagen hier, ich habe da mal was vorbereitet. Ich habe mir diesen Code jetzt auch von von dieser veröffentlichten Basis genommen, selber mal bei mir verändert
äh und getestet und dann diese fertige Änderung, die stelle ich so jetzt hier in so einer Anfrage bereit, sodass man als Entwickler in Anführungsstrichen nur noch sagen muss, so, ja, nehme ich zack
bum und dann ist es halt eingebaut. Ähm habe schon mal ein bisschen rumgeschaut, also ich denke, ich habe so den Eindruck, es war vor allem viel,
so abtasten an der Oberfläche, also es wurden viel Typos, äh Dokumentationshinweise, so Kleinigkeiten, äh gefixt. Das muss ja nichts äh schlechtes sein. Erstens ist das ja auch,
hilfreich und es zeigt ja auch, dass dass man überhaupt wahrgenommen wird, oder?
Ähm ja klar, also es ist natürlich auch ein Aufwand jetzt wirklich sich reinzuarbeiten und Code zu Committen. So und das ist ja auch nicht notwendig, also,
SAP und Telekom wurden ja beauftragt, die App zu bauen. So und wir deswegen machen wir das auch ähm aber dennoch wollen wir halt offen sein für jemanden, der was findet, einen Fehler findet, sei es nur Rechtschreibfehler oder was auch immer
ja, dann kann man auf Gitarren halt ein Pull-Riek-West erstellen und wir schauen uns das dann an. Und ich glaube, auch innerhalb von ein paar Stunden hatten wir eigentlich immer dann, zumindest ein Feedback auf diese Anfrage.
Genau und selbst wenn das Feedback nur an der Stelle war, im Moment, das müssen wir uns nochmal genauer anschauen. Da müssen wir selbst halt nochmal reingehen und das Thema durchdenken. Ähm das heißt,
gerade wenn wir halt die Dokumentation da jetzt anschauen, da gab's schon einige kritische Nachfragen. Warum ist die Entscheidung genauso und so gefallen? Und.
Wir haben uns das natürlich vorher durchaus überlegt und,
Das ist dann aber nicht so, dass man das Architekturdokument hochlädt und alle anderen möglichen Realitäten, wie man es hätte machen können, damit dokumentiert, sondern am Ende steht da halt die eine Lösung, für die wir uns entschieden drin.
Und dann ist das halt tatsächlich auch so, dass wir uns die Tickets oder diese Ische ganz genau anschauen, nochmal durchgehen, okay, haben wir irgendwas übersehen, warum wir das nicht so wie dort beschrieben gemacht haben und sind dann halt auch selbst wirklich bemüht genau.
Aufzuschreiben. Warum haben wir das nicht genau so gemacht, wie vorgeschlagen? Manchmal ist es halt einfach, weil bestimmte Sachen.
Einfach beim Schnell drüber schauen, ausgeblendet werden. Manchmal ist es halt einfach eine Geschmackssache.
Ich habe auch ein bisschen Kritik gelesen, dass ähm wir so viel Dokumentationen machen,
Also ähm da gab's wirklich auf Twitter halt auch Leute, die meinen jetzt investieren, die hier Stunden in diese Dokumente liest, doch eh keiner ähm ein Start-up wird halt einfach die die App entwickeln.
Ich habe die gelesen. Und ich muss sagen, auch.
Dass dass die Dokumentation als erstes da war. Insbesondere diese diese äh Überblicke über dieses Themaarchitektur,
hat mir von Anfang an ein ein äh eine mentale äh Verknüpfung, mit dem gegeben, was da eigentlich entwickelt werden sollte, ohne dass ich mich wahrscheinlich äh so hätte orientieren können. Also der
Code selber
den zu lesen, erfordert ja Kenntnisse in der Poemiersprache, Kenntnisse in dem jeweiligen in Variament und man muss im wesentlichen eigentlich auch sagen wir mal schon halbwegs erfahrener äh Programmierer äh sein, um dem Ganzen in irgendeiner Form dann
äh konkret was abgewinnen zu können, aber solche System äh Überblicke und äh sagen wir mal auch so, so,
Dokumente, die die eigenen Absichten auch
sagen, ne, dass man sagt, das ist unser Ziel, da wollen wir hin und so und so und wir sehen hier auch diese äh Probleme in der Sicherheit oder Privatfirma oder was es auch immer ist, dass das einfach schon mal ausgesprochen wird und und auch
kurdifiziert wird in so einem Textdokument. Das äh habe ich persönlich als extrem hilfreich empfunden. Aber es gab ja dann auch.
Code Review. Also es gab ja dann nach der Veröffentlichung von Zosco Teilen, Leute, die sich dann tatsächlich den gesamten Soundcoot genommen haben,
Ich glaube sowohl im Bäckernd als auch äh auf den äh Smartphone äh Apps, ich weiß gar nicht, gab's eigentlich bei Android auch was, hätte jetzt nur für iOS eins gesehen, hat jemand sowas gemacht.
Aber auf jeden Fall wurde es getan und äh ja, dann wurde dann, was weiß ich,
Getwittert geblockt, äh oft geblockt. Ähm wie kam das bei euch an.
Also eigentlich haben wir uns jedes Mal gefreut, wenn's irgendwo ein Rivio gab. Also das war auch im internen Channel bei uns, wo dann immer direkt ein ein Link geteilt und da hier, guck mal, da gibt's ein neues Revio und ähm,
was dann natürlich auch irgendwie zufriedenstellend war, war letztendlich auch die Bewertung. Also
Oftmals haben wir halt äh das Feedback bekommen oder waren das Ergebnis Reviews. Ähm ja, schon ganz solider Code, nichts spektakuläres,
Hier und da fehlt vielleicht noch ein bisschen was Tests zum Beispiel.
Und ich glaub, das ist einfach ein sehr gutes Feedback letztendlich, also natürlich die Test müssen wir ausbauen.
Aber auch wenn ich mir so eine Chorona Warnapp anschaue, bin ich eigentlich ganz froh, dass da kein spektakulärer Code oder so drin ist,
So und deswegen haben wir halt äh uns entschieden, auch äh moderne Programmierung einzusetzen, aber jetzt nichts besonders abgefahren ist oder so. Also auch im Backendaver, auf Android, also wir haben übrigens für iOS und Android halt nativ entwickelt,
und haben da halt einfach ja Standardsachen genommen.
Ich glaube an der Stelle, dass es halt auch nochmal, wo du jetzt so sagst, Standardsachen ganz relevant zu erwähnen, dass wir wirklich,
nicht hausinterne Standards nur genutzt haben, sondern halt auch wirklich,
Standards, die jeder zu Hause auf seinem Rechner oder äh wenn's hochkommt, auch auf dem ausführen kann. Das heißt, das war uns an der Stelle halt wichtig, dass wir,
keine Datenbank benutzen, für die jemand eine separate Lizenz erwerben muss, dass wir keine Umgebung,
aufsetzen, die äh nur mit wochenlanger Feinarbeit und äh spürnasen überhaupt nachvollziehbar ist, sondern wirklich, dass halt auch der Server einfach ein Dockerfall hat, dass man ausführen kann,
und das halt sofort laufähig ist. Ähm dass man's halt einfach selbst testen kann.
Also er kam auch vom Vorstand mal so die vorsichtige Frage. Ha, können wir da nicht die SAP Hannah Datenbank vielleicht im Becken benutzen und,
und von daher haben wir jetzt eine als Datenbank.
Jetzt ist es ja so, dass es trotzdem irgendwo ja immer Grenzen gibt, wo obens Horst dann auch aufhört, ne? Und äh da gibt's ja hier äh zwei
Teile im Wesentlichen. Das eine ist ähm.
Was wir schon angesprochen haben, diese eigentliche Exporter-Notifikation ab, ja, also das Fremdwork, was das Umsetz auf den Telefonen. Äh kurz gesagt, wie sind denn eure Erfahrungen mit dieser äh mit diesem Fremdworks funktionieren die so, wie sie sollen, sowohl auf äh den Apple Devices als auch den Google
Devices und welche Erfahrungen wurden da gemacht?
Da muss ich als Mobilentwickler an der Stelle äh,
eigentlich begeisterte Freudensprünge machen. Das heißt, meine persönliche Erfahrung, Erfahrung beim Entwickeln, mit Bluetooth, auf Android, ist das, das manchmal schon ein bisschen wehtun kann,
einfach durch die Gerätevielfalt und dann Geräte spezifischen Details wie halt,
Bluetooth implementiert ist, wie man darauf zugreifen kann und so weiter. Also da hatte ich schon einige Stolpersteine und als ich dann,
in der Nacht, als das äh veröffentlicht wurde, das heißt als wir diese Enthaltungen bekommen haben, in unseren Entwicklerprofilen, das austesten konnten, weil sie nur, ich hatte irgendwie bis äh.
Halb eins nachts noch Meetings und dann habe ich mich hingesetzt, noch ein Getränk zur Seite genommen und habe das auf beiden Systemen mal selbst durch implementiert und habe mich.
Doch schon sehr gefreut, als ich dann auf meiner Konsole sehen konnte, da kommt Datenpakete rein. Und das wirklich muss ich sagen, schön.
Benutzbar, also es ist wirklich einfach gehalten, das heißt, man kann auch äh.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, nichts falsch machen, aber das ist halt schon so von den üblichen Vorgehensweisen ein bisschen abweichend, sodass die Anzahl an Fehlern, die man bei der Implementierung machen kann, mit dem Framework niedrig gehalten wird. Und das ist sehr, sehr robust auch ausgelegt.
Also ich persönlich bin mittlerweile ein Fan davon geworden, wie das gebaut ist.
Mhm. Spürt man da irgendeine Geschmacksrichtung? Richtig, es schmeckt das mehr nach Apple oder mehr nach Google oder ist das so eine so eine unheimliche Allianz?
Es ist wirklich schwer zu beantworten, also klar, wenn man sich dann die Spezifikation anschaut, äh dann sieht man jeder hat da so ein bisschen sein eigenes gemacht halt, wie dann diese Schnittstellen implementiert sind. Ähm.
Unglaublich schwer zu sagen.
Wirkliche Kooperation kann man sagen.
Also das war dann auch der andere Punkt, der mich wirklich fasziniert hat, wie einfach.
Das war fast schon so real, wie ich das Dokument auf meinem Screen hatte, wo das Apple-Logo und das Google-Logo direkt nebeneinander waren.
Dann auf der nächsten Seite auch noch irgendwelche Datenpakete aufs Bit runterspezifiziert worden. Das war schon so, war ein schöner Tag, als Entwickler, doch.
Jetzt wird ja äh viel kritisiert, viel kritisiert, dass es so stimmen, die man hört, äh das äh dieses Framework, weil's ja quasi Teil der,
tiefen Kommunikation ist, äh auch hätte Open Source werden sollen. Hältst du das für erforderlich?
Das ist halt eine erste spannende Frage. Also klar, schön, wenn also in der perfekten Welt ist alles Open Source einfach an der Stelle. Da gibt's dann gar keine Grenzen.
Sagten SAPler.
Das sagt äh.
Aber ich glaube, man kann da ganz realistisch auch sagen, irgendwo gibt's dann die Grenze, ähm irgendwo ist halt auch das Betriebssystem nicht geopenezost,
was auf der anderen Seite auch voraussetzt, dass der Nutzer dem Betriebssystem gegenüber halt auch schon ein gewisses Vertrauen mitbringt. Und,
daher ist meine persönliche Meinung, dass das okay ist, wenn das halt Teil des Betriebssystems wird, dass es nicht Open Source ist und das halt wiederum Menschen, die sagen, sie vertrauen einfach diesen Open Source Betriebssystem mehr.
Ähm dann auch an der Stelle.
Im Zweifel äh das Exporte Notification Framework selbst Open Sourcen müssen, weil da steckt ihnen keiner irgendwie äh äh Stöcke zwischen die Speichen.
Sondern das ist alles sauber dokumentiert von Apple und Google, wie's funktioniert. Wie gesagt, aufs Bit runter wirklich. Äh die Protokolle sind alle offenspezifizierte Protokoll Buffets, die an die Server gesendet werden und auch wir haben ja da nichts verschleiert, was die Kommunikation angeht,
von daher würde ich sagen, kann da jeder sich seine Open-Source bauen, wenn er sie haben möchte.
Ich meine, es gibt ja, glaube ich, zwei Gesichtspunkte von Open Source. Also, eine ist, würde man jetzt quasi den Code
konkret die beschriebenen Dinge mal implementiert, so als Referenz rausgeben würde, ist ja solche
darauf aufbauenden Erweiterungen, leichter machen, oder es würde vielleicht manchen auch nochmal ein tieferes Verständnis davon geben, wie es äh tatsächlich funktioniert. Auf der einen Seite, das andere ist ja so dieses, man will gerne überprüfen, dass es auch wirklich das tut, was was oben auf war, Dose draufsteht,
aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich ohnehin durch eine Open-Source-Legung so gar nicht herstellbar.
Eben, weil dann macht man's halt einfach eine Ebene tiefer. Das, was man verstecken will.
Ja oder man gibt Open Source raus, aber es läuft dann doch was ganz anderes auf dem Telefon, was man nicht so ohne weiteres überprüfen kann.
Genau, also das heißt, am Ende ist fast schon physiophisch die Debatte in dann am Ende.
Aber es gibt auch einen Versuch, das Open Sowas zu machen, oder?
Ja, zumindest bei Android, also es gibt halt immer wieder die Frage, ob es irgendwie eine Open Source äh Lösung gibt oder dem Plementierung für das äh Google Apple Protokoll.
Und da hat sich jetzt bei uns im Android Report Tory auch eine kleine Truppe gefunden, in einem Ischu, das können wir auch in die mit reinnehmen. Ähm.
Die letztendlich eine eigene Implementierung von diesem Protokoll halt umsetzen wollen. Also das läuft jetzt unter dem Namen Koral Libre.
Und da bin ich mal gespannt, was bei rumkommt. Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die Leute da auch noch ein bisschen ähm unterstützung haben möchten. Also wenn jemand Lust hat, kann er sich da gerne beteiligen liegen.
Die äh andere Seite, wo der Open Source endet derzeit ist ja dieser Laborserver, dieses Laborinformationssystem, was wir schon äh entwickelt haben. Also.
Leute mal kurz zum.
Überblick, also es gibt im diese zwei großen Komponenten. Der eine ist halt dieser, der redet mit diesem Laborinformationssystem. Und das ist letztlich ein Produkt der Telekom, was ohnehin schon existierte, richtig?
Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht mal sicher, ob das von der Telekom kommt. Ähm da stecke ich einfach nicht tief genug drin. Ich weiß, es existiert auf jeden Fall schon und äh wurde jetzt mal angepasst.
Aber die Struktur des Projektes ist so, dass das an der Stelle eigentlich egal ist, weil es nur die Information durchreicht.
Nicht nur das, da wurde sogar wirklich eine Schnittstelle gebaut, also das Open Source ist immer weiter gekrochen in den Komponenten,
während des Prozesses, das heißt ähm,
das jüngste Mitglied der Open Source Familie in dem Projekt, das dieser Testresalserver. Ähm so dass man, wenn man das betrachtet, wirklich ganz, ganz deutlich sehen kann, dass der in Richtung Labor nur eine Schnittstelle hat, das heißt, dieser testlose Server redet nicht mit dem Laborserver,
proaktiv, sondern machten Schnittstelle für den Laborserver auf, über den halt Testergebnisse in den Testresalserverein gepusht werden können.
Also La Borserver ist das die Software, die tatsächlich beim Labor läuft oder für den läuft.
Genau, das ist halt die spezifische Laborlösung. Ähm muss ich zugeben, habe ich gar keine Ahnung, äh wie das genau aufgesetzt ist, ob das jetzt ein Stück Software ist, was äh auf einem Rechner unterm Schreibtisch an Labor läuft oder ob das irgendwas in der Cloud ist.
Das kann ich absolut nicht sagen. Ich weiß nur, dass von uns halt diese Schnittstelle wirklich definiert wurde, wie die Laborsoftware die Ergebnisse über diesen identifire über diese äh Geoide in,
unsere Welt hineingeben kann.
Das heißt, dieses Laborinformationssystem vermittelt eigentlich mehr, so das Labor des Labor redet dann tatsächlich direkt mit diesem Server.
Potenziell kann das so sein. Wie gesagt, das ist ein das ist so ein ganz, ganz spezifisches Detail.
Okay. Sagst du lieber nichts zu? Okay.
Sage ich lieber nichts zu. Weiß ich nicht.
Aber so oder so, selbst wenn es nicht so wäre, also dort wird wird keine relevante Information noch zusätzlich gespeichert oder.
Genau, also an der Stelle kann man halt wieder, wenn man sich den Code anschaut, schon sehen, es gibt technisch gar keine Möglichkeit,
an diesen Testergebnissserver zum Beispiel noch den Namen oder die Telefonnummer zu übermitteln, weil da gibt's wirklich nur zwei Felder. Und zwar, dass die GUID und das Testergebnis.
Positiv negativ äh Test konnte nicht ausgewertet werden.
Diese ID für diesen Test selber.
Genau diese nicht mal äh,
nicht mal unbedingt für den Test, sondern also das ist diese Kennung, die wird gar nicht intern im Testprozess benutzt, die wird mir einfach an der Seite mitgeschleppt, damit man das dann übermitteln kann. Das heißt, äh intern beim Labor wird der Test zum Beispiel nicht unter dieser Erkennung,
gespeichert. Das halt auch wieder schön so daneben hergezogen, einfach um sicher zu gehen, dass Daten nicht vermischt werden sollen, die nicht vermischt werden so.
An der Stelle können wir ja vielleicht mal jetzt auch den erwarteten Workflow vielleicht mal auspacken. Also jetzt haben wir viel über Software geredet, was alles so in Place gebracht wurde. Jetzt
ist ja im Prinzip erstmal die die App ist mehr oder weniger gerade auf dem Weg in die Welt und die Infrastruktur steht,
Ja, also der Hebel wird jetzt demnächst gezogen werden und,
Das bedeutet, dass ja dann das sozusagen gleich losgehen kann. Ne? Also ich lass mir jetzt mal vierzehn Tage äh verstreichen,
So und ich habe dann meine App die ganze Zeit am Laufen äh gehabt, habe meine ganzen Chorona-Partys äh gefeiert und viel zu enge Podcast aufgenommen und all das.
Und äh dann äh geht's halt los äh mit der Husterei. Ich denke mal so, oh, oh, mal gucken, was jetzt passiert. Was.
Ist jetzt so quasi der äh Modus, also was passiert jetzt, jetzt frage ich so, aha, okay, ich bin vielleicht krank, was wo gehe ich hin, was,
tue ich und wo kommt dann die App das erste Mal ins Spiel.
Du würdest ja jetzt an der Stelle die App eh schon auf deinem Telefon installiert haben.
Davon gehe ich jetzt mal aus, dass ich die schon benutzt habe, installiert habe, aber ich habe ja nichts mit dir getan.
Genau, du bist ja sozusagen schon der Pro-User, der die App nie offen hatte, aber äh installiert hat.
Einmal hat man sie offen, ne? Also sie hat mir das schon mal angeschaut, also man, wenn wenn man die App das ist ja auch sehr ereignis
Abends, so, ne? Also man, manchmal netti, äh, App runter, aber ein Start, dieser hallo hier helfen, lalala, äh darf ich hier Kontakt äh Protokoll benutzen? Ja, mach mal, zack, zack und dann kommt irgendwie eins Green, der sagt ja, okay, ist.
Kannst du wieder zu.
Ich laufe jetzt, ja? Genau.
Ich ich laufe jetzt, ja? Und und das war's ja. Weitere Interaktionen ist nicht, also man kann es einmal starten und dann muss man das im Prinzip nie wieder anfassen.
Im Idealfall hast du eigentlich nichts mehr mit zu tun. Nun sind wir ja doch nicht in der idealen Welt, das heißt, du hast dich an der Stelle eventuell doch infiziert. Mhm. Und jetzt gehst du zum,
sagen wir Hausarzt und ähm der sagt, naja, müssen wir einen Test machen.
Führt dann den Test durch, wie auch immer man das so als Arzt macht, ähm Teststäbchen und so weiter und packt die Proben dann ein,
damit ihr ans Labor gehen könnt und hat dann so einen Probenbegleitschein. Auf dem Probenbegleitschein werden die,
ähm Probenkennung erfasst. Das heißt, irgendwie jedes einzelne Teststäbchen hat dann wieder eine eigene Kennung. Das wird alles auf dem Probenbegleitschein erfasst,
und dann hat der Probenbegleitschein aber zusätzlich noch ein drauf. Das ist wirklich neues Kennzeichen, was einfach zusätzlich eingeführt wurde jetzt,
und dann gibt's für dich auch noch den Infozettel, den du bekommst, wo nochmal draufsteht, hier äh das Testergebnis kann jetzt Elektronisch auch an dich zurück ermittelt werden. Das musst du als Nutzer,
beziehungsweise in dem Fall bisher am Patient. Proaktiv auch nochmal bestätigen, dass das so passieren soll, dass es elektronisch an dich übermittelt, wenn sie.
Okay, langsam langsamer sein. Also diese diese also dieser das soll jetzt, das ist sozusagen ein Novum, der war so bisher da noch nicht drauf.
Sagen wir zumindest, gerade im Rahmen von Corona. Ja. Wurde, ist er neu dazu ge.
Ja. Aber diese, aber diese Idee, das hat mir vorhin ja schon besprochen, dass dieser Test eine ID hat, ist jetzt in dem Sinne nicht neu. Aber sie stand vielleicht nicht unbedingt Maschinen lesbar auf so einem Zettel drauf.
Selbst das war schon drauf, eine Maschine lesbarer ID, aber jetzt wurde halt noch eine zusätzliche, davon vollkommen unabhängige Kennung eingeführt, die wirklich nur dem dient, dass man das Testergebnis,
an einem letzten Bearbeitungsschritt nochmal zurückführen kann, äh auf einem elektronischen Weg. Also das wirklich eine Entkoppelung von den Laborinternen Prozessen.
Okay, also man man verwendet nicht etwas äh mit, was schon geplant war, sondern jetzt neu durch die Corona Warnapp,
wird's ein weiteren Code geben auf diesen Zettel, der für diese Patienteninformationen sozusagen,
die Patientenbenachrichtigung über das Testergebnis gedacht ist. So und dann würde ich also in dem Moment, wo ich jetzt meinen Rachenabstrich äh bekommen habe, beim Arzt und klar ist, welcher Probenbegleitschein jetzt diesen Test äh zum Labor führt,
dann wird dieser Zettel entnommen, mir vor die Nase gehalten und gesagt, Herr Brittlaf, sie haben doch bestimmt die App, so wie ich sie kenne,
So ist es klar. Habe ich. Zück das Teil, Kamera an, klick,
und also mit der App sozusagen sagt man, ich möchte jetzt hier mal scannen und dann ist diese Information über diesen Test, der jetzt ja erst losgeht,
aufmaltelefon.
Gewissermaßen ja. Also das heißt es auch da haben wir wieder noch so einen Zwischenschritt eingebaut, das halt nicht mal der Code äh von diesem QR-Code,
Also nicht die Daten, die da drin enthalten sind, auf dem Telefon gespeichert werden, sondern selbst die werden einfach nur so transient, wie wir sagen, äh hergenommen,
an den Server gesendet und dann gibt's so ein Redgestation token, was sich das Endgerät dann abspeichert,
Das ist einfach dazu da, dass die dass dieser QA-Code am Ende schon verbrannt ist, das heißt, dass nicht mal jemand, der den Zettel danach in die Hand bekommt, das nutzen kann, um das Testergebnis abzurufen.
Das ist wirklich einmal benutzt und dann ist er im Prinz.
Was es finden, wenn wenn ihr schon mal jemand weggescannt hat, das aus irgendwelchen lausigen Gründen, dann kriegt eine entsprechende Fehlermeldung darüber.
Genau. Dann gibt's die Fehlermeldung, deswegen ist natürlich optimal, wenn das direkt beim Arzbacht, den zu scannen, weil dann merkt man sofort im Moment, dass das faul.
Das ist halt, dass äh aus unserer auch wünschenswerte Szenario, dass der so schnell wie möglich konsumiert wird am Ende. Ähm weil das halt auch den die Möglichkeiten zum Missbrauch reduziert,
beziehungsweise, weil's einfach hilft, dass der Benutzer wirklich das Gescannt hat und nicht dann irgendwie eine Woche später denkt, was eigentlich aus meinem Test geworden, den Zettel nicht mehr findet.
Ja. Das heißt, die die App nimmt einfach diese Information, meldet sich im System an und sagt so, hier, ich bin derjenige, der an diesem,
Testergebnis, ein Interesse hat und ich bekomme quasi so eine registrierung für OK du bist jetzt offiziell, hier ist ein Zertifikat, ja, dein dein dein Ausweis, um äh als einziger
dieses Testergebnis digital abfragen zu dürfen.
Genau. So und jetzt haben wir wieder den Punkt erreicht, wo du halt benutzt, da schon wieder die App wegpackst und schon wieder sagst, ne, jetzt kann ich wieder nichts mehr machen. Ähm.
Ist wirklich langweiliges Spiel. Ein Stern.
Und jetzt ist aber die Sache, jetzt gibt's wieder verschiedene Wege, wie man das technisch lösen kann, das Testergebnis, die aufs Telefon kommt, der ganz einfache, intuitive Weg wäre zu sagen, wir pushen das einfach über eine Push-Nachricht aufs Telefon und fertig. Ähm.
Das ist natürlich aus Datenschutzsicht mittelkatastrophal bis sehr katastrophal.
Weil es ja bedeuten würde, dass dieser Server sich quasi so eine Referenz auf mein Telefon merken müsste, die ganze Zeit.
Genau und das, das zum einen, dann würde es natürlich äh nicht mehr über unsere Infrastrukturen laufen, sondern das wird dann halt über einen Server, über diesen Push-Server von dem jeweiligen Geräte,
oder Betriebssystemhersteller laufen und das ist halt bei Gesundheitsdaten und so ein Testergebnis, glaube ich, wirklich unbestritten. Ein Gesundheitsdatum, absolut unerwünscht.
Das heißt, wie es jetzt am Ende läuft ist, dass wenn das Telefon in deiner Tasche ähm sich fast schon langweilen könnte, dass die App dann trotzdem im Hintergrund regelmäßig gegen unseren Server checkt.
Gibt schon Testergebnis.
Und der äh hat auch wieder eine indirektionsebene, womit er das dann überprüft. Und wenn dann der Fall vorliegt, dass das Testergebnis da ist. Das heißt, positiv, negativ, Auswertung nicht möglich,
dann ist es nicht etwa so, dass die App dann sofort schreien würde, hier, das ist dein Ergebnis, sondern gibt's halt wieder diskrete Benachrichtigung.
Testergebnis liegt vor? Dann kannst du die App wieder rausholen, dann kommt die große Stunde und dann,
bekommst du das Testergebnis präsentiert. Das heißt, das Testergebnis wird halt auch nicht in der App gespeichert, sondern immer, wenn du es als Benutzer zu sehen bekommst, weißt du, das wurde gerade erst so vom Server abgeholt.
Und ja, dann ist natürlich die Frage, was ist rausgekommen? Für dich der Idealfall wäre, negativer Test,
Weißt du, das äh Problem lässt sich vielleicht doch mit dem Kamillentee lösen. Oder wenn's dann halt doch der positive Test war, dann gibt's natürlich Handlungs äh Empfehlungen, was du machen solltest,
das heißt an der Stelle.
Wenn du positiv auf Saßkopf zwei getestet wurdest, solltest du natürlich auf gar keinen Fall mehr rausgehen, da gelten ja halt die äh Quarantäne-Regelungen und.
Erstmal Canauel feiern. Erstmal Karneval feiern.
Ich habe noch ein Meeting.
Und aber genau das ist dann halt so die Information, die man auch hält, das ist wirklich eine ernste Sache. Ähm bitte.
Ich glaube ja schon, dass wenn man schon zu einem Test geht, wahrscheinlich sich ohnehin schon eine gewisse Verhaltensänderung einstellt, aber das ist natürlich dann ein negatives Ergebnis dann auch sofort, sagt, okay, alles klar, ich kann mich wieder entspannen.
So und dann weiß man zumindest, okay, es hat jetzt auch einen Grund gehabt, mich hier zurückzuhalten.
Genau. Und wenn der positive Test halt vorliegt, gibt's auch wieder diese Handlungsempfehlungen, die dann wirklich ernst sind.
Die Frage an dem Nutzer? Möchtest du jetzt deine Diagnose Schlüssel der letzten vierzehn Tage äh teilen, damit andere Personen, mit denen du in Kontakt gekommen bist.
Von ihrem Telefon, die Information erhalten können, dass der Kontakt vorlag. Über nicht wird ja wieder niemand erfahren,
sondern das ist ja, das ist ja das ganz charmante an diese Technologie, dass halt deine Schlüssel dann einen Server gehen, der Server mit den Schlüsseln.
Technisch gesehen im Prinzip gar nichts macht, sondern die einfach nur eine lange Liste anhängt und nochmal,
einmal durchrührt, äh damit die halt in der Zufallsreihenfolge sind, sodass man halt nicht sagen kann, ah, der Schlüssel gehört zu dem, zu dem Thema. Also, dass man diesen Zusammenhang zwischen den vierzehn Schlüsseln, die du hochgeladen hast auch nicht mehr wahrnehmen kann,
und dann laden sich halt alle kleinste Schlüssel runter äh und können halt lokal abgleichen,
habe ich den schon mal irgendwo gesehen und falls das der Fall ist, dann dort die jeweilige Benachrichtung wieder lokal an den Benutzer geben. Das heißt, auch in dem Fall.
Sind alle Benachrichtigungen nur lokal nur vom Telefon selbst generiert, ohne irgendwelche Externserver dann wieder darüber zu informieren, dass eine Benachrichtigung erfolgt ist. Äh,
oder halt äh das über irgendeinen wilden Serverumweg zu machen zu benachrichtigen. Es passiert wirklich lokal.
Jetzt hör so äh vermute mal.
Änderung in der Art und Weise, wie Tests ausgerollt werden, heißt, das funktioniert bestimmt nicht gleich überall äh durchgehend.
Wie viele Laboren müssen eigentlich so unterschieden werden in Deutschland? Also.
Also ich habe vorhin mal die Statista ähm Angaben geschaut und ich glaube, wir haben gerade,
hundertsechzigtausend äh Testkapazität pro Tag und hundertdreißig, hundertvierzig Labore. Also.
Die sind natürlich jetzt alle erstmal nicht sofort angebunden ähm und es ist auch die Frage, wie ist überhaupt die Verteilung? Also es gibt halt ein paar richtig große Labore, die viel testen und dann halt einige kleinere.
Also Labor Berlin, vor allem hier in äh in Berlin, wieder in Hamburg schon sagte eine äh Charité angebunden, ist so einer der dicken Wegschaffer, gibt noch ein paar andere sehr große Labore, aber es gibt auch noch ein paar kleinere.
Genau. Ähm jetzt ist es leider so, dass äh mit dem heutigen Tage halt äh kaum Labore angebunden sind. Ähm die werden jetzt alle noch ähm.
Dieses diesen Prozess ähm,
müssen und ähm da müssen wir jetzt zusehen, dass das halt recht schnell vonstatten geht. Also da ist dann auch wieder ein bisschen äh das Gesundheitsministerium gefragt, dass die da halt entsprechend Druck machen. Ähm ja,
weil letztendlich bringt's halt nichts, wenn man eine App hat, aber man kriegt halt kein Testergebnis oder man kann halt äh seine Kies nicht hochladen.
Wobei, es gibt ja diesen anderen Weg, über diese Telefonhotline, das zu machen. Also, in dem Moment, wo mein
Test, den ich jetzt erhalte, nicht diesen netten QR-Code drauf hat und ich in meiner App nichts sagen kann, hier registriert dich mal automatisch
ist es ja trotzdem so, dass dieser Test existiert und ich dieses Ergebnis abfragen kann und dass meine App mitteilen kann. Das ist jetzt ein Test.
Richtig. Das kann ja auch an der Stelle sein, dass du einfach gesagt hast, du möchtest, das Testergebnis nicht elektronisch übermittelt bekommen.
Man hat's nicht hinbekommen oder.
Hat den Zettel verloren.
Oder man hat den Zettel verloren oder sonst so wie irgendwas ist ja immer.
Und da haben wir halt diesen, ich sage mal, Vollbackworkflow, integriert über die.
Teletan, also der wohlklingende Name ist übrigens entstanden, weil bei uns irgendwann plötzlich fünf verschiedene Sachen dran hießen und wer dann einfach die Begrifflichkeit nur auseinandergezogen haben.
Teletan klingt wie so ein Produkt aus den Achtzigern.
Schreibt so gut, was es halt ist. Also ich wir hatten die Diskussion war, das heißt Teletan, das hört sich voll an, aber ich hab gesagt, hey, nee, komm, lass los.
Irgendwann ist es dann auch wirklich mehr ans Herz gewachsen, dass es weiter so heißen sollte. Und das hat's ja dann auch in die Dokumente reingeschafft.
Haben so ein paar schöne Namen hier, auch Proben, Begleitschein, den du grad genannt hast.
Der heißt wirklich so.
Das ist aber ein Begriff, glaube ich, aus dem, aus der Laborwelt, so. Das gab's ja schon vor.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist eine äh Begriffswolke, die halt einfach gut zusammenpasst. Also Probenbegleitschein, Teletan und Corona Warn-App, also.
Schon für dich alles eins geworden.
Aber der Prozess ist dann halt an der Stelle, wenn wir halt den QR-Code nicht haben, dann sollten wir natürlich trotzdem, wenn wir positiv getestet wurden, andere.
Indirekt warnen lassen können, durch ihre jeweiligen Apps. Und damit das passiert, müssen wir unseren positiven Test irgendwie in Verbindung mit den auf dem Telefon gespeicherten Schlüssel bringen.
Vor allem, wenn ich das nochmal sagen darf,
Ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass ich nicht jetzt schon zum Testen zum Hausarzt gehen könnte und dann kann ich irgendwann meinen Hausarzt anrufen und dann guckt er mal, ob das Ergebnis da ist. Also ich habe von Leuten gehört, da hat es,
zehn Tage gedauert bis irgendwelche Antikörperteste sind wahrscheinlich,
Generell, es gibt so gewissen Turnaround. Und im Prinzip will man ja die Information ab dem Moment, wo sie beim Labor vorliegt und nicht, wo sie Dritten mitgeteilt wurde.
Genau, also ich meine der Worst Case ist wahrscheinlich, wenn man die Information erst vom Gesundheitsamt dann erhält.
Weil die werden ja wiederum auch vom Labor informiert, sehe Paragraph neun Infektionsschutzgesetz. Und wenn die anrufen, dann,
ist höchstwahrscheinlich schon einiges an Zeit vergangen. Das heißt, wenn man erst vom Gesundheitsamt informiert wurde, dann.
Das ist dann so der Anruf bei mir, so Herr Brittler, warum melden sie sich denn nicht äh ihr Ergebnis liegt doch vor äh et cetera.
Ja, na gut, aber es kann wohl tatsächlich auch vorkommen, dass die die erste Stelle sind, die Kontakt aufnehmen, um das Testergebnis mitzuteilen. Also, das ist auch nicht auszuschließen, da verliert man natürlich einiges an Zeit.
Also Idealfall, wenn jemand den QRA Code nicht hat, wäre, dass der Arzt sich telefonisch dann beim Patienten meldet, um das mitzuteilen.
Ja. Aber der Arzt kann mir keine Teletannen geben, aber das Gesundheitsamt könnte das theoretisch.
Im Prinzip, wenn das Gesundheitsamt das wollen würde, könnte man die äh auch an dieses System anbinden, dass die halt diese Teletanz generieren können.
Würden die das auch wollen.
Das ist wiederum eine Frage, die,
auf dem eben genannten Weg irgendwo erklärt werden müsste, ob die das wollen, ob die das vor allem stemmen können, weil nach einem, was ich gehört habe, sind die Gesundheitsämter halt momentan auch schon wirklich.
Ähm gut beschäftigt und muss sagen, Hut ab vor den Damen und Herren, die da halt einfach diese Arbeit machen, die sich die Zeit nehmen mit den einzelnen zu telefonieren. Und ich glaube, die.
Na gut, aber jemand in dem Moment, wo sie sich die Zeit nehmen, mich anzurufen, um mir mitzuteilen, dass ich positiv getestet bin.
Sozusagen in Anführungsstrichen nur noch erforderlich über diesen dritten kleinen Minister, den ihr da noch am Start habt, ist ein Portal Server,
für diesen, also für meine Person, quasi dieses Ergebnis äh was ihn ja eh schon vorliegt und damit haben sie auch diese ID für diesen Test, ne?
Mir dann eben so eine Tan zu generieren.
Das ist ein ganz, ganz klassisches Jahr, aber. Äh was man darauf antworten kann, weil das war nämlich auch unser Ansatz in der Stellennah, dann könnten die das ja schnell miterledigen.
Und dann steht man plötzlich an der Stelle, dass man den ja aber halt auch schon koordinierten Zugriff auf das System geben möchte. Das heißt, es soll ja dann nicht einfach Lokin mit Benutzernamen, Gesundheitsamt und Passwort, Gesundheitsamt, eins, zwei, drei sein,
sondern man müsste dann jedem einzelnen Mitarbeiter im Gesundheitsamt, der die Gespräche führt und dass Deutschland weit äh,
adäquaten Benutzerzugang geben und dann wurde das Ganze plötzlich wieder in Dimension auswachsen, wo man schauen muss, wie man das vernünftig ausgerollt bekommt. Und das war dann die Stelle,
wo wir auch gemerkt haben, oh, ist doch nicht so einfach, wie gedacht. Und das dann, wo dann die Hotline ins Spiel gekommen ist, weil man die halt viel viel schneller äh und viel konzentrierter auf die Beine gestellt bekommt, weil's da halt nicht so verstreut, viele Mitarbeiter gibt,
die eigentlich ja auch ganz andere Aufgaben zu tun haben, sondern die Hotline-Mitarbeiter können dann halt wirklich darauf fokussiert werden, können halt darauf,
angelernt werden und haben dann halt auch diese persönlichen Zugänge, die sie brauchen, um die Teletanz zu generieren.
An der Stelle muss man, glaube ich, gleich mal sagen, Hotlines gibt's zwei. Genau. Und das ja, die heißen haben wir beide auch, also.
Glaube, die eine heißt technische Hotline tatsächlich? Ja. Ähm.
Ja. Das wird sich nicht durchsetzen, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Vielleicht kann man ja Telehotler äh.
Desk. Also das eine ist gedacht, um Leuten mit der App zu helfen.
Genau. Die Halswäscheprobleme haben bei der Installation der App, die Fehlermeldungen bekommen äh beim Starten-App, sei es zum Beispiel, weil das äh Bluetooth nicht aktiviert wurde oder einfach auch um Fragen zu klären ähm.
Wenn's auf bestimmten Telefon einfach nicht geht, weil das ist ja eine Sache, ob in der Dokumentation steht, dass das auf dem iPhone sechs nicht mehr funktioniert, aber auf dem sechs ist.
Doch äh ist doch eine Buchstabeunterschied und ich glaube, das sind halt genau Themen, die halt auch in dieser Hotline besprochen werden können.
Okay, also es gibt so, ich sage mal jetzt mal Helpdes, damit das nicht äh verwechselt wird, ja. Äh so eben diese technische Unterstützung, aber die eigentliche Hotline ist dazu gedacht, mir Testergebnisse.
Ähm bestätigen zu können und dann äh mir entsprechend diese Teletan zu geben.
Genau.
Und die Herausforderung an der Stelle ist natürlich dann wieder, dass es kein zentrales Register aller durchgeführten Tests gibt. Das heißt, äh die Hotline kann halt nicht einfach in einem System nachschauen, wurde die in die Person gerade.
Aber ich dachte, es gibt diesen Laborinformationsserver.
Ja, das wäre ganz gut, aber wenn die Daten an denen übermittelt worden werden, dann hätten wir auch den. Das heißt, wenn wir davon ausgehen müssen, dass das Labor nicht angebunden ist.
Ach so, dieser QR-Code ist sozusagen die Voraussetzung oder das Zeichen dafür, dass er an diesen Labor in Formations, aber okay, wenn's denen gar nicht gibt, dann ist es auch nicht dort.
Genau, das ist leider äh an der, also leider für uns, keine zentrale Infrastruktur, die es da gibt. Äh das würde es bedeutend einfacher machen, sondern wir müssen halt davon ausgehen, dass es auch Labore gibt, die,
ich sag's mal ganz platt, nicht mit der Außenwelt reden und diejenigen sollten natürlich trotzdem die Möglichkeit haben, ihre Kies hochzuladen.
Das heißt, worüber kriegt er diese Hotline, die Informationen her über meinen äh Testergebnis.
Dass dann ein Klausibilisierungsverfahren angesetzt. Das ist halt so ein.
Spagat am Ende zwischen dem Datenschutz und äh dem Gewähren des Zugangs. Das heißt, da gibt es dann einen Fragenkatalog, mit dem die Mitarbeiter der Hotline.
Sicher gehen äh wollen, dass wirklich ein Test durchgeführt wurde. Das sind dann halt spezifische Fragen, mit denen das nachvollzogen werden kann.
Wo habe ich das gemacht? Wann habe ich das gemacht? Wie heiße ich? Traalala.
Ich kenne den Fragenkatalog jetzt auch nicht, von daher vermute ich.
Ich vermute nach dem Namen wird nicht gefragt werden. Ähm weil das ja am Ende wieder Daten, die wollen wir gar nicht haben.
Stimmt. Ja, okay.
Ähm und auf dem Wege bekommen wir dann die Teletan.
Halt nochmal über den ähm das ist so ein Datenschutzhinweisen dann auch äh beschrieben, dass man dann halt seine Telefonnummer angibt und nochmal den Rückruf erhält von der Hotline einfach um.
Da auch noch eine weitere Hürde für, ich sage mal, Schatzanrufer einzubringen.
Also man muss ganz ehrlich sagen, es ist eine Übergangslösung. Äh,
Notdürftig ein bisschen. Und unser Ziel muss ganz klar sein, halt eine große Abdeckung der Labore zu bekommen, dass wir da diesen letztendlich umsetzen können,
und ähm ja, da ist halt jetzt auch wieder ein bisschen die Politik auch gefragt, entsprechend äh Druck zu machen, auf die Labore, dass wir die wirklich hier anbinden können.
Aber zumindest gibt es diesen Pfad. Also es gibt eine relativ klare Vision, wie man da so eine vollständige Digitalisierung und äh insane Notifizierung hinbekommen kann, an der man sich jetzt orientieren kann. Jetzt ist es eher nur noch eine Frage der Umsetzung.
Das ist genau der aktuelle Stand, also die technischen Voraussetzungen sind komplett geschaffen, dass man das auch nutzen kann.
Jetzt,
werdet ihr sicherlich auch mitbekommen haben, dass es in der Öffentlichkeit allerlei Diskussion, um diese App äh gegeben hat, da ist ja der ein oder andere Artikel und der ein oder andere Blogartikel auch schon mal veröffentlicht äh worden. Manche hauen sich da richtig die Köppe ein,
weil es natürlich sehr unterschiedliche Auffassungen darüber gibt, was man denn sich jetzt sozusagen von dieser ganzen Geschichte äh versprechen kann oder,
sollte. So, ja, also das geht ja vorn mit
diese App wird uns alle retten und ab morgen können wir uns alle gegenseitig den ganzen Tag wieder küssen bis hin zu, das ist ja alles nur technische Spielerei und das bringt ja überhaupt nichts
Was ist denn so eure eigene.
Wahrnehmung dieser Diskussion und vor allem auch die eigene Wahrnehmung, der der Nützlichkeit, dieses Systems. So wie es gedacht ist und vielleicht eben auch so wie es bisher ausgerollt ist.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass die App das Zeug zum Allheilmittel hat,
Also da gibt es keine Hinweise drauf, dass wir jetzt durch die App wieder also durch die App alleine in unser altes Leben irgendwie zurückfinden,
aber es ist halt ein Baustein. Also, es unterstützt letztendlich das Kontectracing, was halt durch die Gesundheitsämter gemacht wird. Ähm.
So, mehr kann man da aber auch gerade nicht erwarten. Äh jetzt ist es so,
gibt's ja die Studie aus Oxford, die halt sagt, okay, ab zwei Drittel der Bevölkerung, wenn die halt eine funktionierende Contectracing-App haben, dann bringt die echt viel.
Also die Aussage war, dann kriegen wir zusammen mit dem normalen Kontaktracing, das den Ausbruch unter Kontrolle.
Genau. So und äh jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, okay, kriegen wir überhaupt zwei Drittel hin?
Äh wahrscheinlich nicht. Also, so ehrlich muss man da auch sein, wahrscheinlich kriegen wir jetzt nicht von den achtzig Millionen äh die Deutschland rumlaufen, weiß ich nicht, sechzig Millionen mit einer App ausgestattet.
Aber dieselbe Studie hat ja auch nicht gesagt, es müssen sechzig Prozent sein, damit es überhaupt irgendwas hilft, sondern bei sechzig Prozent hätte man schon so diese massive Auswirkung, es ging ja sogar noch weiter mit, wenn's achtzig Prozent sind, dann brauchen wir sogar nur noch die App.
Weil das alles so automatisch äh äh läuft, dass der Virus einfach die weiße Flagge rausholt und sagt, also wer das,
wenn das so ist, dann gehe ich, ja? Aber es kann natürlich auch schon vorher von Nutzen sein und dieser Nutzen steigt quasi quadratisch mit der Verbreitung an.
Also auch wenn weniger die App benutzen, bringt es halt schon was, wenn's halt ein Alarm gibt. Weil jeder der halt einen Alarm bekommt, der weiß, er hat halt Kontakt zu einer Person, die infiziert ist,
und dann äh achte ich mal lieber auf mich, macht vielleicht nochmal einen Test oder sowas und ähm tu oder kann dann aktiv etwas gegen die Verbreitung dieses Virus ähm halt tun.
Und ähm das ist letztendlich auch der Nutzen, den die App bringt, auch wenn wir jetzt nicht eine ähm sechzig, siebzigprozentige Abdeckung halt haben.
Was man ja an der Stelle auch nicht vergessen darf, ist, dass halt diese sechzig prozentige Abdeckung nicht mal äh über die gesamte Bundesrepublik vorherrschen müsste, sondern tendenziell ja.
Regional das auch schon genauso wäre, das heißt, selbst wenn man entländlichen Regionen nur eine Abdeckung von zehn Prozent hätte, aber in den Städten achtzig.
Wurde, dass er in den Städten sich halt lokal dann genauso bemerkbar machen. Einfach, weil das ja immer diese Zahlen sind ja nur für denjenigen relevant, in dessen Umgebung gerade was passiert.
Also da kommen auch schon wieder eigentlich in ein schwieriges Thema, was so ähm ja diskriminierung durch ähm fehlende App-Benutzung letztendlich angeht, also wurde schon ein paar Mal besprochen, äh das Restaurant, was halt nur noch App benutze, halt reinlässt.
Fußballstadien et cetera, also alles Ganzen.
Genau, also der Gedanke ist ja äh irgendwo berechtigt, dass man halt sagt, hier kommst du nur rein mit einer App,
aber ähm es ist halt eine Diskriminierung. So und deswegen sollte halt die App immer freiwillig sein. Äh was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ist, dass man halt,
ähm Mist, okay, wie viele meiner Besucher haben, denn überhaupt eine App. So und wenn man lokal halt schon feststellt, okay hier ähm die Leute, die jetzt hier in diesem Gebäude arbeiten oder was auch immer, haben zu sechzig Prozent die App, dann,
habe ich auch regional, schon einen großen Nutzen letztendlich aus dieser App,
So und wenn ich dann über Informationskampagnen, äh, Lokal, ähm, die Verbreitung auch steigern kann, ähm, kann das, glaube ich, auch schon wieder einen großen Effekt haben.
Und was wir auch nicht außer Acht lassen dürfen. Ähm es gibt ja auch in den Restaurants, die auslegenden Listen, wo man auch jetzt schon dann halt äh Name, Telefonnummer.
E-Mail-Adresse, Adresse, dem ist ja keine Grenze gesetzt, was da gerade erfasst werden muss, bei jedem Restaurantbesuch. Und.
Das darf man auch nicht außer Acht lassen, dass das jetzt schon in Place ist sozusagen, das ist gefordert wird und das ist ja.
Ich glaube, dass die App jetzt nicht einen Ersatz dafür wird für diese Listen, die wir in den Restaurants haben.
Aber halt auch keiner satz für den gesunden Menschenverstand.
Also, sie könnte es vielleicht werden, wenn sie einen durchschlagenden Erfolg auf einmal nachweisbaren durchlagenden Erfolg äh hätte, aber man muss sich auch klar machen, dass
dass das eigentlich die Alternative ist, eine permanente Erfassung aller Kontakte in Schriftlicher Form in einer Ausführlichkeit, äh wie diese App sie ja selber,
nicht macht, weil genau diese Informationen, die ich in meiner Restaurantliste eintrage, diesen wenn dieser App nicht übermittelt und äh die App hat auch kein,
Zugriff da drauf. Also sie könnte diese, also könnt ihr natürlich die versuchen, die Information zu erfragen, aber dann gäb's wahrscheinlich auch gleich Stress äh mit Apple und
Google, wenn das der Fall äh wäre, aber sie kann auch nicht systemisch irgendwie sich diese Information ranholen, weil sie einfach diese Zugriffsrechte ja gar nicht äh hat.
Jetzt gibt's in dieser ganzen Geschichte aber noch ähm Parameter.
In der technischen Spezifikation heißt es glaube ich, also in dem Moment, wo man diese Keys von infizierten,
Empfängt und dann eben unter Ausnutzung dieser AP sagst du hier liebes Telefon, ich habe hier mal ein paar infizierte für dich, guck doch mal,
ob wir die gesehen haben, dann gibt es ja noch ein paar Parameter, mit denen das Ganze nochmal weiter eingekreist wird. Und das ist ja quasi die Aufgabe der App, diese Parameter mitzuliefern. Also das Telefon entscheidet nicht,
vollständig alleine wie ein Kontakt festgestellt wird, sie definiert nur die Art und Weise
wie das geschieht, aber was genau geprüft wird, ist zumindest in bestimmten Parametern nochmal,
äh genauer einzuengen. Also da gehört die Dauer des Kontaktes dazu in so fünf Minuten, Schritten, da gehört eine,
Einschätzung äh dazu,
welche Tage jetzt welche Relevanz haben, weil wenn ich weiß, dass jemand jetzt gerade eben getestet wurde, dann war der vor zwei Wochen nicht auch schon
Infektiös diese ganzen Sachen und es gibt auch noch eine Reihe von.
Ich glaube, die Spezifikation sagt so, äh, Applikationsdefiniert, also wo man sich selber noch ein bisschen was ein äh ausdenken kann, was irgendwas bedeuten kann. Also wie wird
dieses gemacht, wo kommt diese Information her? Wer hat sich darauf geeinigt und was wird derzeit jetzt eigentlich konkret getestet?
Die Informationen halt für genau diese Parameter. Also wenn man das äh Solution Architektur Dokument vor sich hat, dann gibt's dazu ja auch ein extra Kapitel. Und das sind halt diese ganzen blauen Zahlen, die da festgelegt werden. Ähm,
die passiert halt nicht durch uns, sondern halt durch die,
Fachleute im Gebiet der EPD-Miologie. Also sprich, dass Robert Koch Institut, die dann halt genau festlegen, wie hoch ist das Risiko oder wie verändert sich das Risiko über die Kontaktzeit,
wie es das einzuschätzen halt das Risiko in,
Zusammenhang mit der Signalstärke. Da kommt dann halt auch wieder das Fraunhofer Institut ins Spiel, um halt genau dieses Mapping über die über den Zwischenschritt der Entfernung äh zu ermöglichen. Das heißt, da wird halt,
extrem zusammengearbeitet.
Um dann halt zum Beispiel sagen zu können, wenn wir eine Signaldämpfung von zweiundvierzig Dezibel hatten, dann ist das jetzt Risikostufe.
Sieben und fünfundvierzig Dezibel sind aber Risikostufe fünf nur noch zum Beispiel.
Also die Skala ist mal von eins bis acht, ne?
Null, null bis acht. Das hat sich auch nochmal zwischendurch geändert. Das ist das ist immer aufregend gewesen, wenn so in der Beta-Phase Updates reingekommen sind, von dem Framework und das dann plötzlich nicht mehr eins bis acht Uhr null bis acht war. Ja ja, ne?
Ach so, das habe ich gleich mitbekommen, okay.
Das war glaube ich auch eine Forderung vom RKI. Also die haben gesagt, hey, wir hätten auch gerne mal eine Null da mit drin, äh erweitert das doch bitte.
War auch ganz spannend zwischendurch wurden die Risiken mal ausmultipliziert und dann addiert. Jetzt werden sie alle miteinander ausmultipliziert und äh.
Auch das hat natürlich dann immer die Berechnung hinten dran angepasst und das wurde halt vom Robert Koch Institut definiert, wie genau das geschehen,
soll, kann man halt auch an der Stelle wieder transparent nachverfolgen, was sich da geändert hat, weil man einfach von dem Dokument die Gitarre durchschaut.
Weil wir das halt auch einfach selbst live geändert haben.
Das heißt äh auch da gab's nix hinter versteckten Türen. Aber ein Parameter, der halt noch besonders spannend ist an der Stelle ist dieser Transmission Resquare, den du angesprochen hast, der halt individuell,
durch die App definiert werden kann und ein möglicher Verwendungszweck, der zum Beispiel gerade wirklich im Gespräch ist.
Darüber abzubilden, wann die Symptome bei den Patienten begonnen haben. Weil das halt aus.
Aus wissenschaftlicher Sichten sehr, sehr spannender Faktor für die Wahrscheinlichkeit eine Übertragung der Krankheit ist, zu schauen, wann hatte derjenige Symptome, sodass man halt sagen kann, okay, ich bin dem an dem Tag begegnet, als die Symptome gerade angefangen haben,
Also jetzt mal über den Bogen schon komplett rumzuspannen,
dann ist es vielleicht kritischer, als wenn ich demjenigen begegnet bin, fünf Tage, bevor bei ihm die Symptome angefangen haben, weil da.
Zum Beispiel noch gar kein Infektionsrisikobestand oder das Infektionsrisiko sehr gering war.
Was mir nicht so ganz klar war, beim Betrachten dieser Spezifikation.
Ist das von vornherein als ein in eine Information, die pro Patient gebildet wird, gedacht gewesen oder ist das eine allgemeine Aussage über den Krankheitsverlauf, dem typischen.
Dieser äh Transmission Risk Parameter, der ist nicht nur pro Patient definiert, der ist sogar pro einzelnem Kidin, man hochlädt definiert, pro Tag, genau.
Ag. Okay, aber dann muss, dann ist das ja eine Information, die mit der Übermittlung des Testergebnisses auch quasi mit dabei ist. Und wenn der Schlüssel veröffentlicht wird, an diesem Schlüssel mit dranklebt.
Genau, der klebt an dem Schlüssel mit dran, der kommen nicht mit dem Testergebnis mit,
sondern wird halt auf dem Endgerät des Nutzers gebildet, wenn man jetzt halt den Symptom beginnt, zum Beispiel mit Abbilden wollen würde, müsste man dem Benutzer dann noch fragen und dann muss auch genauso nein, möchte ich nicht sagen, eine validee Antwort sein.
Oder vielleicht gab's ja auch keine, man kann ja auch.
Man ist a symptomatisch, dann muss das genauso kommunizierbar sein. Ähm jetzt der aktuelle Ansatz ist ähm, weil wir diese zusätzliche Anfrage an der Minute halt äh in der ersten Version nicht integriert haben,
es ist einfach abzubilden, wie viele Tage das Testergebnis zurückliegt. Ähm das heißt, an jeden Schlüssel ist angehängt, wie alt das Testergebnis.
Am Tag des Schlüssels war,
und äh darauf hat halt das Robert Koch Institut auch wieder einen bestimmten Risikoparameter definiert, ähm sodass man das halt in diesem Zusammenspiel zwischen wann wurde der Test durchgeführt, dann kann man abschätzen.
Wie viele Tage liegt's für gewöhnlich her, äh bis der als der Test durchgeführt wurde. Und nach wie vielen Tagen sind die Leute zum Arzt gegangen, nachdem Symptome begonnen haben. Also das heißt, je mehr Annahmen man treffen muss, wird's natürlich ähm.
Unschärfer, aber man hat halt diesen zusätzlichen Wert und dann gibt's natürlich eine Parameter noch, wie viele Tage lag der Kontakt zu der Person zurück,
und äh das kann man kann dieses Framework dann halt intern auch wieder zu einem Risiko errechnen.
Ist da eure Erwartung. Ich meine, das ist ja jetzt sozusagen ein interessantes ähm
sammelt Syrien an Stellschrauben, die man jetzt hier hat, ohne dass an der Software selber groß was geändert werden muss, kann man im Prinzip permanent sowohl, was jetzt das Tuning der einzelnen veröffentlichten Schlüssel betrifft, als auch das Gesamtverhalten der App, eigentlich die ganze Zeit
äh dran drehen, um das irgendwie feiner einzustellen. Um das zu können, müsst man natürlich auch in gewisser Hinsicht,
Ergebnisse haben, an dem man das äh bewerten kann. Daran mangelt sie ein gewisser Hinsicht. Das war ja immer so eine ähm Kritik auch an dem dezentralen Modell, das ja sozusagen so ein dieses, ja, was,
Was findet denn bei dem Vergleich tatsächlich statt, dass diese Information vollständig in der Blackbox stattfindet und äh einem selbst auch keinerlei Rückmeldung geben kann.
Das ist halt so eine Tücker. Aber am Ende auch wirklich eine aktive Entscheidung, die diese Ergebnisse dieser Risikoauswertung dann nicht weiter zu teilen,
weil technisch gesehen könnte man natürlich sagen, okay, wir bauen jetzt wieder die Brücke zurück zum Betreiber, also zum Robert Koch Institut ein, sagen,
Hier, der User wurde gerade gewarnt oder der Test ist so und so, also diese diese Vertestung des Risikos ist so verlaufen, dass kein Risiko vorliegt, das könnte man ja zurückspielen,
aber da haben wir uns alle zusammen in Absprache aktiv dafür entschieden, das eben nicht zu machen,
Das heißt, sobald der Benutzer irgendwas auf dem Gerät angezeigt bekommt, bleibt es auf dem Gerät und die Daten fließen halt nicht zurück. Einfach auch um, um dieses Vertrauen an der Stelle zu schaffen.
Also, das RKI und auch alle anderen müssen halt jetzt erstmal ein bisschen lernen äh mit äh der Gegebenheit umzugehen. Also was bringt diese App, wie ähm
ja was,
kommt letztendlich bei raus. Funktioniert das mit dem Facing und so weiter. Und wenn man dann ähm ansetzte, findet, wo man irgendwie noch einen ähm bestimmten Datensatz bräuchte oder so, dann kann man natürlich ähm,
das auch erweitern in offener freiwilligen Basis letztendlich, dass man weitere Informationen ähm dass der Benutzer auch weitere Informationen bereitstellen kann,
was wir aber nicht machen wollten, war erstmal ähm,
vorsorglich so viel Daten sammeln, wie es geht, um dann zu gucken, ob man damit überhaupt was anfangen kann. Also es geht hier nicht um äh wirklich Daten sammeln und dann Data Mining zu betreiben, sondern ähm.
Mit der Philosophie der Datensparsamenkeit letztendlich ähm vorzugehen und dann nur das zu erheben, was man wirklich braucht. Und ähm.
Wenn es über diese,
grundlegenden äh Daten hinausgeht, die für's Contact Racing halt benötigt werden, dann auf einer freiwilligen Basis äh letztendlich diese Daten auch zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Weil wir werden Präsident zwei Ansätze so spontan einfallen, wie man das Problem verhältnismäßig elegant,
lösen äh könnte. Das eine ist natürlich das, was ich jetzt eigentlich anbiete, dass man erstmal sagt, naja okay, wir stellen's jetzt erstmal vielleicht ein bisschen schärfer ein
Als wir gedacht haben, ja, wir gehen vielleicht mal nicht von fünfzehn Minuten aus, sondern wir machen mal zehn Minuten oder äh man dreht auch diese an dieser Signalstärke äh ein bisschen äh rum und sagt, ja, okay, wir sammeln jetzt vielleicht mal,
etwas mehr ein, als wir selber meinen, als eigentlich nötig wäre, weil dann bekommt man ja quasi,
generiert man, dass er so auch eine Angst in dieser ganzen Diskussion, oh mein Gott, falls positives, et cetera, aber man fordert ja dann sozusagen mehr Leute auf,
potenziellen Test zu machen. Ist natürlich schwierig, weil dann man quasi mehr Leute dazu drängt, sich erstmal zu,
isolieren und zumindest für ein oder zwei Tage mehr Vorsicht walten zu lassen, als vielleicht angemessen wäre, also ich verstehe schon, dass das schwierig ist, aber so, das wäre ja sozusagen ein Ansatz.
Zweiter Ansatz, der mir so einfallen würde, wäre die,
Zusammenarbeit mit Google und Apple, weil diese Informationen, die in diesem Freienwork anfällt, ließe sicher anonymisiert wiederum hinten rum einsammeln.
Es gibt ja diese Mobility äh Daten von Google und Apple, die halt über diese Differenzial Privacy, also sozusagen wir übermitteln mal die Informationen, anonym
aber nicht nur anonym, sondern auch mit so einem gewissen Fehleranteil, sodass eben nie von irgendeiner Information einzeln gesagt werden kann, dass die stimmt, aber wenn ich alle zusammennehme, dann kriege ich wiederum das richtige Gesamtergebnis, ne, also sozusagen so eine, so eine so eine gleichmäßig verteilte Fehler
Kurve, die sich dann am Ende von alleine wieder rausrechnet. Das wäre so äh ein anderer Ansatz, der vielleicht auch noch akzeptabel wäre.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich denke, da werden wir halt letztendlich auch noch ein paar Leute brauchen, die halt wirklich ähm aus dieser Statistik sicht mal draufschauen und gucken, was man machen kann
Also, ich glaube, auch ein sehr interessante Information wäre letztendlich. Okay, ich gehe jetzt zum Test, weil ich wurde gewarnt und wie ist dann das Ergebnis halt äh
ausgegangen. Bin ich dann positiv. Einfach diese Information, okay, ich wurde gewarnt und dann ist es jetzt positiv oder negativ. Dadurch kann man ja auch schon ein bisschen ähm
die Schärfe kalibrieren letztendlich dieser Alarmierung.
Aber da müssen wir natürlich auch wissen, wodurch man gewarnt wurde, ne? Also man ist ja auch dieser diese Parameter, die in dem Moment zum Einsatz kam, in gewisser Hinsicht äh noch mit eingesammelt werden.
Ja, weiß ich nicht unbedingt. Also, ich glaube, es wird schon einfach helfen, ähm also wenn man sieht, okay es werden extrem viele Leute einfach gewarnt und die gehen zum Test, aber haben da nichts.
Dann ist es so hart.
Kann man ja ein bisschen äh die Kriterien runterdrehen.
Weiter, was man daraus ableiten kann, ist, es muss in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein.
Eine Toleranz sich äh breit machen, ne? Um sozusagen diese Ed Cases dann auch zu ertragen. Auf der anderen Seite könnte das natürlich auch dazu führen, dass die Leute es dann nicht mehr so.
Ernst nehmen, wenn dann tatsächlich was wieder rot, naja, hat sich letztes Mal schon und so, mir noch egal, ne. Wie habt ihr das,
diskutiert, wie man diese Benachrichtigung konkret gestaltet, also wie werden die Leute von dieser App angesprochen,
Also,
Klassiker war ja am Anfang so, ah, Alarm, ja so alles leuchtet, rot, das Telefon vibriert, hab's schon von alleine vom Tisch runter, so ist es ja nicht, oder?
Genau, das ist halt wirklich gratis, dass er vorhin als Nebenschauplatz äh.
Bezeichnet. Diese ganze User-Experience Geschichte, weil ich glaube, dass es sogar eines der Kernthemen bei der Entwicklung der App, weil das halt so ein sensibles Thema ist,
weil das halt so ein Thema ist, wo so viel Vorsicht auch in der Kommunikation zwischenmenschlich geboten ist.
Weil ich will natürlich nicht, dass wenn ich mit den Kollegen grade äh am äh sauber distanzierten Essenstisch sitze.
Dann die Meldung aufploppt, du wurdest positiv getestet und die Kollegen sehen das sofort alle und sagen wo ganz schlimm.
Sofort, dass man so einen Ton hat, so.
Und dann weiß jeder, aha, hier er ist infiziert.
Das ist halt eben genau nicht der Fall, sondern natürlich, man sieht dann die Informationen ähm potenziell von der App, es liegt ein Testergebnis vor.
Kann sich dann aber schon ich sag mal, in Sicherheit begeben, bevor man das Testergebnis anschaut.
Und genauso ist halt auch der Fall, wenn sich der Risikostatus geändert hat. Auch da gibt's dann soweit, ich weiß, die Benachrichtigungen, der Risikostatus hat sich geändert und erst beim öffnen der App bekommt man halt dann wirklich zu sehen, was der tatsächliche Risikostatus ist.
Und da gibt's auch gar nicht so viele Stati. Da gibt's am Ende geringes Risiko und das erhöhte Risiko. Einfach weil zusätzliche Differenzierung.
Da dachte ich auch erst so wieder aus der Entwickler denken, das ist doch super, dann geben wir dem.
Dem Benutzer einfach den Risikosrohr ist das super, wenn er schon auf eins bis acht normiert ist, dann weiß er, vier Komma fünf ist mein Risiko. Ähm.
Ja, es wohl aus User Experience sich dann doch nicht so gut, sondern was soll der User denken, dein Risikos mittelt oder sagen, na, ich ich gehe jetzt noch jeden zweiten Tag raus und von daher, das,
habe ich dann auch eingesehen, dass das sinnvoll ist natürlich, wenn sagt, das lieg.
Geringes Risiko vor, oder es liegt das hohe Risiko vor oder natürlich der Fall, wir können gar nichts über das Risiko sagen, weil die App noch nicht benutzt wurde.
Das sind also im Prinzip die drei Stufen, die es gibt.
Genau. Wir haben allgemein das Problem, dass die App eigentlich recht komplex ist. Auch ähm die App zu erklären, was sie wirklich macht, um halt diese Akzeptanz zu bekommen,
Also es gibt viele, die halt sagen, oh, nee, hier aus Datenschutzgründen, äh, habe ich keine Lust, da äh mitzumachen,
die die App schaut ja in meinen Adressbuch rein. Ja nee, tut sie nicht, ja da natürlich, wie sollen sonst meine Kontakte ähm informiert werden.
Und solche Diskussionen haben wir halt einfach und ähm.
Das, das, also, ich bin gespannt, wie es jetzt weitergeht und auch ähm wie die PR-Kampagne jetzt laufen wird, die diese App umwirbt äh oder.
Und,
Ich bin echt gespannt, was am Ende bei rauskommt. Also es, ich glaube, dass man wirklich mit Vertrauen letztendlich da auch arbeiten muss, weil ähm es ist kaum möglich, dass ein großer Teil der Bevölkerung wirklich versteht, was letztendlich hier passiert.
Immer schwierig, das äh zu fühlen, aber ich denke, man muss sich auch einfach mal klar machen, das ist alles für alle Beteiligten neu,
So, es ist eine neue Idee für ein neues Problem, wo man erstmal schauen muss, äh wie ist das? Gewisser Hinsicht haben wir jetzt auch noch ein bisschen Zeit so, also zumindest in Deutschland sind wir jetzt gerade in so einer Situation, wo,
das Schlimmste vorerst, vorerst im Griff zu sein scheint
und wir uns ja im Prinzip für eine Phase wappnen, wo eben auf einmal alles nicht mehr so einfach ist, beziehungsweise man äh dessen dann halt schnell her werden kann. Und da ist sicherlich noch ein bisschen Zeit jetzt eben auch schon die besprochenen
Feder aufzugreifen und vor allem dieses Feintuning vorzunehmen und dann vielleicht auch mehr darüber zu erfahren, wie man eben die Ansprache äh halten muss. Et cetera.
Was natürlich jetzt,
auch noch eine große Frage ist, jetzt haben wir viel über Deutschland gesprochen, aber wir sind ja nicht alleine auf der Welt und äh vor allem nicht in Europa und haben äh viel Grenzen mit äh unseren äh Nachbarn, wo Leute regelmäßig rüber pennen, pendeln, Leute wollen in den Urlaub fahren
et cetera, sprich die Frage der internationalen Kompatibilität, die stellt sich ja und
dass Google Apple Modell, das Protokoll sieht ja im Prinzip vor, dass wenn jetzt alle Apps in allen Ländern mit diesem Protokoll arbeiten, dass dann diese ganzen
ausgetauschten Informationen, diese ganzen veröffentlichten Kies, miteinander kompatibel sind. Jetzt haben wir natürlich einige Länder, die diesen Weg,
zumindest bisher so nicht beschritten haben, aber selbst wenn man jetzt mal hier unseren Mikrokosmos anschauen, wir haben jetzt Deutschland, wir haben die Schweiz, Österreich und Italien, das ist ja zumindest schon mal so ein Zusammenliegender Blog.
Die tatsächlich alle auf das selbe Modell aufsetzen. Da sind auch schon.
Zwei sind also jetzt mit der Corona Warnapp und der Immuni, Apple, die teilen, glaube ich, zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon zwei veröffentlicht, die Schweizer,
brauchen glaube ich noch ein, zwei äh Wochen. Ich habe, glaube ich, von Anfang Juli gehört, ich weiß nicht ganz genau und äh in Österreich sieht's glaube ich ähnlich aus, da gab's zwar schon die App, aber die wurde ja dann umgestellt auf das neue Modell. Ähm,
Gehen wir jetzt mal davon aus, das würde jetzt auch in allen vier Ländern bereits laufen,
Meine Chorona Worn-App, die redet mit meinem Corona Wardserver und ähm da bleibt das ja dann alles erstmal in Deutschland. Was ist jetzt sozusagen die Lösung, die Europäische und die internationale Lösung? Wie ist das jetzt gedacht
das äh auch wenn sich einen,
eine Schweizerin und eine Österreicherin in Deutschland auf einer Konferenztreffen, dass sie dann trotzdem noch benachrichtigt werden kann,
deutscher Krank geworden ist oder ein Italiener sogar.
Erst einmal überlegen, okay, warum gibt's denn nicht einen Server für alle? Das weiß auch, ich sage mal Google.
Weltserver.
Google jetzt hier den Welt zu erwarten aufmacht. Also das hört sich schon so furchtbar an, aber äh.
Die könnten das. Wäre Datenschutztechnisch kein Problem, weil wissen wir ja, die Informationen sind nicht das Problem, sondern die Menge der Daten, das ist das Problem.
Wobei man hier vielleicht auch ein Akzeptanzproblem hätte. Also es war auch ganz klar Vorgabe an uns. Ähm wir sollen keine Google Amazon oder Microsoft-Server benutzen, sondern bitte,
ähm in Europa besser noch in Deutschland letztendlich selber benutzen.
Deutscher Cloud.
Genau, deswegen kamen wir dann auch zur Telekom.
Jetzt haben wir bei dem Dezentralen System ein kleines Problem, wenn's wirklich um richtig, richtig viele Leute geht, sprich.
Fünf oder sieben oder acht Milliarden oder wie viele wir gerade haben? Ähm dadurch, dass jedes Handy ähm jede Infektion sozusagen checken muss, ob äh da in Kontakt äh bestanden hat,
müssen diese weltweite, muss diese weltweite Anzahl an Infektionen auch an jedes einzelnen Handy verteilt werden. So und ähm das ist halt.
Also die der Datentransfer wächst sozusagen exponentiell mit äh den Teilnehmern. So dass wir.
Jetzt hier einen Datentransfer haben in Deutschland, der händelbar ist für ähm ja Begegnungen.
Genau genommen wechseln nicht mit den Teilnehmern exponentiell, sondern es hängt ja auch noch ein bisschen davon ab, wie viele Leute infiziert sind, also so so.
Also einmal, du hast ja die Anzahl der Handys, die Daten runterlädt und die Menge der Daten pro Handy ist bestimmt durch die Anzahl der Infektion.
Genau, aber die Teilnehmer selber, dass er eher so eine line Jahre, ja.
Genau, das ist Lenear, aber dann mit den Infektionen.
Schnell exponentiell, wie wir wissen.
Machen wir mal ganz schnell den Taschenrechner auf an der Stelle. Ähm gestern gab's so über den Daumen gepeilt hundertzwanzigtausend neue Infektionen.
Weltweit.
Die Kies, die hochgeladen werden für die letzten vierzehn Tage, das ist eigentlich, also es ist wirklich kompakt, das sind vierhundert bei. Also das kriegen wir notfalls noch äh auf die Lochkarte gelocht.
Aber,
wenn wir jetzt das skalieren, diese vierhundert bald mit hundertzwanzigtausend Neuinfektionen sind wir schon über den Daumen gepeilt bei fünfundvierzig Megabyte,
und das sind nur die reinen Nutzdaten, jetzt meine Daten natürlich übertragen, haben noch ein bisschen ein paar Protokolle dabei, wenn wir das ordnungsgemäß über HTPS machen, ähm haben wir noch den Handshake dabei,
der uns bei diesen vierhundert bei nicht etwa so mit hundert weit ins Gewicht klickt, sondern da sind wir locker mal bei drei Kilo bei. Heißt, wir können Faktor zehn rechnen,
haben wir plötzlich schon vierhundertfünfzig Megabyte. Gut, sagen wir unser Serverschnitt, das schön zusammen. Der Upload ist aber noch nichts, was nicht Sorgen macht. Müssen wir vierhundertfünfzig Megabit pro Tag hochladen auf dem Server,
geschenkt. Jetzt müssen wir das aber runterladen und zwar auf jedes einzelne Endgerät.
Da können wir denke ich ungefähr mit Faktor zwei rechnen, da haben wir jetzt also neunzig Megabyte, die jeder Nutzer weltweit runterladen möchte,
äh am Tag am Tag. Und jetzt mal wild in die Runde überlegt, wie viele von wie vielen Teilnehmern gehen wir denn aus an dem System?
Weltweit, alle die Telefon haben. Wer vielleicht schon fast ein bisschen zu viel, aber mal eine Milliarde nimmt, ist es äh.
Nehmen wir mal eine Milliarde, ne? Das war schon, muss man schon aufpassen beim Tippen. Da haben wir also jetzt schon neunzig.
Äh Billionen Megaarbeit,
teilen, weil jetzt haben wir Gigabyte, dann haben wir Taraby, dann haben wir Ex-Arbeit, haben wir also schlanke dreiund,
vierundachtzig, schlanke vierundachtzig Exerbeit täglich, die der äh heruntergeladen werden müssen. Ähm.
Und da darf nicht schief gehen bei der Übertragung.
Aber dann müsst man sich das doch eigentlich so überlegen, es gibt auch jetzt dieses Darlehenssystem von Space Ex.
Machen wir die Auslieferung der Daten einfach über diese dreitausend Satellitennieder rumfliegen? Also ich glaube, wir müssen da noch ein bisschen dran.
Irgendwo müssen wir dann halt feilen, weil jetzt könnte man natürlich weitergehen und sagen, okay, wir laden nur die Daten von den Regionen runter, wo ich gerade war und wenn ich infiziert wurde, wird es nur in die Region geschoben. Ähm,
auch wieder aus Entwickler sich gedacht, natürlich alles ganz einfach. Da muss man ja gar nicht so einen Stress machen. Aber dann kommen da wieder so Themen rein, die man einfach.
Muss man ja ganz ehrlich sagen, nicht auf dem Schirm hat, dadurch, dass wir am Ende hinreisen können, wo wir wollen,
es interessiert keinen, aber in anderen Ländern ist es halt schon so, dass die Regierung das halt nicht begrüßt, wenn ich in anderen Regionen war und dann möchte ich nicht, dass meine Chorona.
Das dann einfach meiner Regierung vielleicht mitteilt,
wenn auch nicht direkt aber auf jeden Fall herausfindbar macht. Das heißt, das gilt's dann auch zu verhindern. Ähm.
Ja, vielleicht gehen wir mal einen kleinen Schritt zurück, also ähm die Frage ist ja, wie kriegen wir die Daten reduziert, die jedes Handy runterladen muss,
So und wenn ich jetzt in Deutschland bin und halt auch nur andere Leute mit einer deutschen App treffe, reicht das ja vollkommen, wenn ich jetzt mit dem deutschen Back-End auch rede,
Das Problem ist ja wirklich jetzt ähm wenn jemand reist,
Also ob jetzt ein Franzose hierher kommt oder ob ich ein Franzosen halt in Österreich treffe oder was auch immer. Ähm.
Diese Verbindung muss man ja irgendwie abdecken. Und dann interessiert mich eigentlich auch nur halt diese Infektionszahlen oder die Infektionsmeldungen aus Frankreich und nicht die aus den USA oder aus der Türkei.
Richtig, also da war jetzt einfach so aus wieder aus Entwickler sich gedacht, mein Gedanke na ja, wenn wir da jetzt hier diese dreiundzwanzig äh weit Bordkasten oder es sind ja,
Es sind ja eigentlich nur äh zwanzig Bedenkstaten, die wir da rüberschieben. Machen wir noch einen weit dazu, dass die Länderkennung von der Person, die da gerade rumläuft.
Problem gelöst, dann weiß ich, aus welchen Ländern ich Menschen getroffen habe und mein Telefon kann das passend runterladen.
Nun das ist auch wieder ein Punkt, den hatte ich da halt gar nicht dran gedacht, dass man damit natürlich äh ein technisches Mittel zu Diskriminierung von Menschen aus bestimmten Ländern schaffen könnte.
In dem einfach schon die App, Broadcast, ich komme aus dem und dem Land. Und das geht natürlich auch wieder nicht.
Also das ist das sind so viele Fallstricke, die es da zu Bedenken gibt einfach, weil nicht jeder die Freiheiten hat, die wir hier genießen können, sondern weil's da so viele Einschränkungen gibt.
Das letztlich ist ja auch eine Idee, ähm dass die App selber weiß, in welchem Land sie gerade ist. Und in welchen Ländern sie die letzten vierzehn Tage war. Und ähm dass man dann dort die jeweiligen Backends halt auch nach Infektionen fragt.
Aber wie weißen, dass die App, wenn sie selber nicht nach der Location fragen darf.
Dass aktuell funktioniert das noch nicht, es gibt diesen Gedanken, dass diese App oder die die API von Apple und Google äh den aktuellen Ländercode mit exportiert. Das tut sie aktuell nicht, aber ähm,
ist eine Überlegung.
Du meinst deinen Bauberg Country Code.
Genau den Mobil Country Coach, den man über die Basisstation letztendlich dann auch bekommt. Also über normal ELTE, weil sich in welchem Land, ich.
Oder halt auch tatsächlich eine Location Auswertung, die aber nicht als solche an die App weitergereicht wird, sondern einfach nur als reduzierte Information, also so wie ich, dass sie, bist du gerade in Deutschland.
So und dann beim Upload würde halt die Information mitkommen. Ähm zu diesem Tag war ich in Deutschland und in Österreich zum Beispiel,
So und wenn man diese Information jetzt im Backend hat, kann man halt auch die Daten entsprechend dann andere Back-Eds verteilen oder man geht halt über einen zentralen Europaservice-Server, der halt das dann nochmal verteilt auf die einzelnen Länder.
Ähm.
Das wäre letztendlich eine Möglichkeit, andere Länder von meinem Infektions ähm Status zu informieren. Also, ich war jetzt in in äh Österreich und äh.
Bin jetzt.
Positiv getestet, äh meine Daten landen jetzt sozusagen auch auf dem österreichischen Server. Wenn jetzt äh die Französin halt auch in Österreich war und ähm.
Selber nicht infiziert ist, aber sie trotzdem halt äh wissen will, okay, vielleicht da in Kontakt, dann weiß die App okay, sie war halt auch in Österreich und ruft entsprechend auch die Infektion aus Österreich ab.
Für diese zwei Wochen Zeitfenster um dieses Jahr hier immer geht. Also es ließe sich quasi automatisieren auf dem Telefon, derzeit können das die APs nicht, aber es ist ja durchaus etwas, was in einer nächsten Version nachgereicht werden könnte.
Und so hätte man auch dieses Konferenzproblem letztendlich gelöst. Also man muss also jede App ähm
Auch die nur empfängt, muss sich halt merken, in welchen Ländern sie war,
und auch wenn man jetzt die Kies hochlädt, muss zu dem jeweiligen äh Tageski halt dann noch die die Länderinformation drinst,
also das können auch mehrere Länder sein. Wenn ich zum Beispiel in Barcelona umsteige oder so, dann habe ich vielleicht ähm drei Länder, in denen ich an einem Tag fahren, dann war ich in Deutschland, in Spanien und bin nach.
Weil sie nicht Marokko geflogen oder so.
Wirkt halt aber wieder die Türke, dass du aktiv kommunizieren musst, in welchen Ländern du warst und setzt voraus, dass äh dass es für dich keine Einschränkungen bedeuten kann, wenn du kommunizierst, wo du warst.
Richtig. Und da sind wir, also,
da, also es kann auch ein Problem sein für äh für Deutsche, letztendlich. Also man kennt das ja, wenn man mit einem Pass irgendwo in äh Länder rein äh fliegt, da muss man teilweise aufpassen. Äh in welchem Land ich vorher war, weil ich sonst nämlich komische Fragen gestellt bekommen,
und da muss man dann auch nochmal ein bisschen Gehirnschmalz reinstecken, wie man diese Situation letztendlich verhindert.
Also dass das Telefon sich nicht dadurch sozusagen selber äh petzt dem sagt so, ah ich bin jetzt hier mal in Portugalser, war ich mal ein bisschen geguckt und ich habe mal im Spanien zugeguckt und da weiß man sofort, ah, du warst wohl in den letzten vierzehn Tagen da.
Hallo Portugal und Spanien sind jetzt, glaube ich, nicht so das Problem, aber.
Aber drauf an, wo man hinfährt. Ich wollte jetzt mal getrost etwas neutrales äh nennen, weil letztlich ist es ja auch egal.
Ja, also ich.
Aber am Ende könnte man ja sogar den Netzverkehr an der Stelle wieder überwachen, zu schauen, mit wem redet mein Telefon grad? Und damit wieder Dinge ableiten.
Ja gut, es sei denn, es gibt sozusagen so ein so ein so ein so ein ähm Server, der eben für alle anderen Länder äh was einsammelt. Also das würde ja dann auch erfordern, dass ich dann quasi meine Kies auch
gleich freigebe für alle andere Länder, dass man das sozusagen umdreht, vielleicht ist das ja auch das richtige Modell.
Ich bin da sehr optimistisch, dass wir das für ähm Europa schaffen,
Weil ähm gerade Schengenraum ist ja kein Problem, wo du warst und das äh sollte eigentlich auch nicht so ein großes Problem sein, dass da irgendwie äh einem Nachteile entstehen, wenn man, wenn ich jetzt in Spanien oder in Italien war, ähm,
und ich meine, eine Sache, die wir halt hier noch beachten müssen, kompatibilität zu anderen Ländern, es muss halt alles nach diesem Apple Google Protokoll halt laufen. Und äh,
das tut's halt gerade nicht. Also England benutzt nicht die Google, ähm Apple, Epi, Frankreich, hat ein zentrales System und ähm,
Also ich habe die Hoffnung noch nicht aufgegeben. Ich glaube, alle Länder schauen sich gerade an, was jetzt hier aus dieser deutschen App, ähm, wird. Also, was hier passiert. Äh,
wird das ganze ein Erfolg und man sollte man eine Wirksamkeit sehen, glaube ich, sind wir.
Relativ schnell dabei, dass wir sehen, okay, es gibt eine weitere Doppe, die sagen, dieses ganzen Google Apple Frame Works,
und ich glaube auch, dass vielleicht am Ende sogar Frankreich noch umsteigen könnte.
Meine Frankreich hat ja derzeit überhaupt gar keine Option auf eine europäisierung, auf eine internationalisierung mit dem zentralen Ansatz, oder?
Ja, ich glaube, Frankreich hat auch selbst gerade noch keine iOS Unterstützung. Also da hast du halt verloren, wenn du halt ein iPhone hast.
Also das ist ja kein kein System, was irgendwie richtig durchdacht ist, oder?
Ich äh habe auch nicht so den Eindruck und meine Einschätzung ist, dass es jetzt wahrscheinlich etwas äh Zeit braucht, bis dann alle so ein bisschen klein beigeben, um dann einzusehen, dass einfach jetzt
Kompatibilität, die europäische Kompatibilität mindestens äh einfach viel wertvoller ist als ich sage mal so
sekundäre Heilsversprechenden, dieses ganze zentrale Modell war ja nur deshalb wirklich so sehr auch in der Diskussion
weil man ja nachvollziehbarerweise ebenso diese Hoffnung hatte aus diesem Modell aus dem Betrachtungsmodell
mehr Informationen zu gewinnen, aber umso mehr wir jetzt hier darüber reden und sehen, wie viele
Ecken und Kanten das an sich noch hat, glaube ich halt auch immer weniger, dass dass dieser eine kleine relativ kleine Aspekt allein jetzt in irgendeiner Form irgendeiner nennenswerte Verbesserung ähm mit sich gebracht hätte, wenn man doch
so viele andere Probleme hat, die es auch noch zu berücksichtigen und die auch in gewisser Hinsicht, wie wir das jetzt zum Beispiel an diesen Ländermodell gesehen haben, auch noch Optimierungs
Potential hat, weil ich glaube, so wie wir jetzt diese App und dieses System äh beschrieben haben, wird es wahrscheinlich in einem halben Jahr
so schon gar nicht mehr sein, sondern es wird in einer Form äh so Evolutionsstufen genommen haben, dann wissen wir noch gar nicht so richtig, was am Ende äh steht.
Ja, man muss ja heute auch schon immer das Datum dazu sagen, wenn man irgendwie was schreibt oder was sagt.
Habe ich das überhaupt.
Weiß nicht, wir haben heute den fünfzehnten sechsten.
Heute den fünfzehnten Juni und das offizielle bis der sechzehnte Juni vielleicht wird's auch schon ein paar Stunden früher aufschlagen, wird sich zeigen ja wir sind sozusagen am Vorabend
des Releases und äh blicken jetzt erstmal gespannt darauf, was denn jetzt passieren wird. Ähm.
Zum Schluss ah, es war eine Sache, muss noch fragen, es gibt eine Beschränkung auf einen Alter, Sechzehnjährige,
der da noch irgendwie Informationen.
Also.
Mit den Kindern macht ist, dass es nur Liegetext, ja?
Ja ich glaub schon.
Weil das wäre jetzt ein bisschen ähm bekloppt, wenn man jetzt ausgerechnet die äh potenziellen Brandherde der Schule hier rausnehmen sollte. Das werden wir mal sehen, wie sich das entwickelt. Aber äh was ich zum Schluss nochmal aufbringen wollte, ist so,
Abgesehen von der Diskussion um die App als solches, hat es ja auch ähm glaube ich eine gewisse Welle gemacht und wir haben das ja hier, als wir über Open Source schon gesprochen haben, ist schon äh gesehen, dass ja hier auch.
Auf einmal ein anderes Modell, wie wir öffentliche Projekte machen durchgezogen wurde,
Auf einmal ging's schnell auf einmal ging es transparent, auf einmal ging's mit Open Source, aber auch mal geht's mit nachvollziehbar, es ging mit Dokumentationen und man hatte auch eine gewisse Beteiligung
Ich will jetzt hier nicht,
zu viel draus machen, aber was ist so euer Gefühl inwiefern dieses Projekt so eine kleine Vorlage sein kann, wie wir künftig mit öffentlichen Projekten umgehen sollten,
im Softwarebereich.
Also ich hatte es vorhin ganz kurz mal angesprochen, wir haben ja auch schon jetzt innerhalb der SAP Diskussion, was Open Source angeht. Und auch ähm,
ja ich glaube, wenn man einfach äh die Firmen danach fragen würde, hey, wir hätten gerne von euch,
diese und dieses hofft wir halt entwickelt. Aber bitte macht es halt Open Source.
Dann glaube ich, ist da auch ein Weg, das so zu machen. Und ich glaube, auch bei der, bei dem Projekt, was wir hier jetzt gerade haben, hat man einfach gesehen, dass es erfolgreich ist oder erfolgreich sein kann,
das ist jetzt natürlich was ganz Besonderes diese App, weil halt ganz viele Leute halt drauf schauen und interessiert sind, was denn da überhaupt jetzt passiert, aber ich glaube, einen Grund auch, weshalb wir das Open Source machen, ist, dass es auch,
andere Länder sich anschauen können. Und dass wir da einfach offen arbeiten. Und warum sollte jetzt eine Software, die halt,
ausschließlich für den ähm Einsatz im Public sozusagen gedacht ist, warum sollte die denn jetzt Closed sein.
Und ähm natürlich können wir die jetzt nicht nochmal verkaufen, nach äh Österreich oder sowas, weil die ist halt jetzt schon da. Aber ähm.
Ja
Kannst das halt auch so bepreisen, indem du halt einfach sagst, okay, wir machen jetzt, sage ich mal, Stundenbasierte, Abrechnung oder sowas, entwickeln die Software auf Stundenbasis und nicht als, als Fixpreis oder so, damit wir dann nachher noch fünfmal verkaufen können.
Beziehungsweise man kann ja auch wirklich seinen öffentlichen Entwicklungsprozess einsteigen und einfach sagen, okay, wir bauen da jetzt weitere Komponenten an, die beiden binden das dann eben an unserer Gesundheitssystem an und
äh das deutsch-spezifische äh lassen wir einfach weg und dann wäre ja auch, äh, was geholfen.
Also, was wir immer noch haben, ist individualisierung. Das heißt, da gibt's dann auch nochmal äh die Möglichkeit halt ähm bisschen Kohle zu machen letztendlich, wenn man halt eben verschiedene Länder geht. Ähm aber auch,
hast Support und Betrieb? Also das äh kann man halt nicht einfach kopieren,
von der Grund äh von der Basis letztendlich diese Applikation, die kann ich halt einfach übernehmen, die muss halt einmal entwickelt werden,
und dann geht's halt immer noch ähm darum, okay, jetzt muss ich Anpassungen machen, jetzt muss ich vielleicht einen Supportvertrag ähm schließen und ähm,
ja, vielleicht das Ganze auch hosten. Also, was halt die Telekom gerade macht oder halt auch die, die Hotline betreiben.
Aber ich finde abgesehen jetzt davon, dass die App als solche natürlich noch andere Wege finden kann, äh eben diesen, diesen Entwicklungsprozess
Als solches interessant, insbesondere weil er sich eben im Gesundheitswesen abspielt und das ist ja eigentlich in den letzten Jahren, das dauert in Deutschland gewesen. Also da gibt es
überhaupt gar keine transparenz, es gibt unglaublich teure Projekte, die vollkommen absurde,
Security, Privatsphäre, Modelle haben, die Liste ist da extrem lang, was da alles irgendwie nicht geht und im Prinzip ist gefühlt irgendwie noch gar nichts passiert in den letzten zehn Jahren
Gesundheitskarte hin, Gesundheitskarte her, aber dass wir wirklich von einem
sowohl einem automatisierten Gesundheitssystem sprechen, was auf der anderen Seite auch die Gesundheits äh die Gesundheitsdaten richtig behandelt und einem auch allen das Gefühl gibt, dass das richtig behandelt wird. Davon sind wir dann auch relativ weit entfernt. Und da würde ich mir schon versprechen
ähm dass man jetzt äh hier mal genau draufschaut und sich anschaut, so aha, okay. Vielleicht geht's ja auch äh anders, indem man die Sachen,
in der Öffentlichkeit entwickelt und dadurch eben auch sehr viel mehr Leute mit einbezieht und es dann am Ende auch nicht immer so eine,
Ja, so eine so eine Medienschlacht wird, wer denn jetzt hier irgendwie wieder den größten Security-Back gefunden hat, sondern dass man diese ganze Energie halt konkret in die Umsetzung der Probleme stecken kann.
Ja haben wir noch irgendwas vergessen.
Liegt euch noch äh irgendwas auf dem Herzen, was ihr gerne noch kommunizieren möchtet.
Vielleicht Berichterstattung ist eigentlich ein ganz interessantes Thema. Also ich glaube auch, dass die Medien hier jetzt auf einmal eine neue Situation vorfinden. Also sind die wirklich dabei, wie 'ne Applikation entwickelt wird und Sie haben nicht einfach nur ein fertiges Produkt,
worüber man äh diskutieren kann, was halt einfach so steht und wo man dann Video machen kann und äh Kritik übt hier, dass das und das ist halt,
äh schlecht.
Was wir halt jetzt ab und zu gesehen haben, auch äh in der Fachpresse. Also es ist nicht, dass es jetzt hier, weiß ich nicht, irgendein Sonntagsblatt oder so, da berichtet dann auch die Fachpresse ähm.
Geht auf Fehler ein, die halt in der App drin stecken und ähm sagt dann, okay, hier muss jetzt noch dran gearbeitet.
Jetzt ist es bei uns so, dass auf Ischus die halt reinkommen, so schnell reagiert wird, dass diese Fehler meistens schon behoben sind, bevor dieser Artikel online geht.
Und vor allem, was man auch nicht vergessen darf. Die Aussage hier muss noch dran gearbeitet werden, hier na klar, machen wir auch. Es ist nur halb transparent, dass wir gerade dran arbeiten.
Ah, das war schon manchmal echt lustig, weil da kommt ein neuer Artikel, du liest dir das durch und ähm ja, hier da und da gibt's ganz große Sicherheitsfehler und ähm,
wir sind einigermaßen überrascht, schauen dann erstmal durch unsere Ischos, weil halt auch immer geschrieben wird, ja, ist schon aufgetaucht und so und da müssen sie jetzt dran arbeiten, wir gehen
durch die offenen Tickets durch, finden nix,
so und dann, ah, das muss dieser Back von vorgestern gewesen sein und so. Und ähm ich glaube, das ist halt neu, auch für die, also sie haben, sie berichten hier über so eine Art.
So und ähm ich glaube, da wäre es auch sinnvoll, wenn in diesen Artikeln vielleicht direkt auf die einzelnen auch verwiesen wird, damit man auch nachvollfolgen kann, okay, worum geht's denn da,
weil es bringt halt auch keinem was, wenn ich einen Artikel schreibe, ich schreibe hier da und da ist jetzt ein Problem,
Datenbank Zugänge zum Beispiel ähm dann wird das veröffentlicht und keiner weiß mehr, okay, worum gings denn da überhaupt? Also das ist halt.
Das ist eine veraltete Information, die auf einmal online geht. Und äh.
Das ist so ein bisschen als Viertelmann über den, über die würde man mehr oder weniger live über die Entwicklung des Linos Körnels äh berichten, ja? Ich sehe schon so wie so Sp,
Berichterstattung. So, ja, hier wird ein neues äh Softcootfall in den Editor geladen, der Casa rückt vor auf Zeile dreiundsechzig.
Also ich meine, wir sehen ja sogar Berichterstattung aus der Linux Entwicklung, aber das ist halt meistens so, ah, hier Linus Torwart hat wieder das und das gemacht oder weiß ich nicht, letztens kam irgendwie, wir brauchen uns nicht auf achtzig Zeichen in einer äh Zeile beschränken,
solche Berichterstattungen sieht man halt vom Linox-Körner. Ähm aber so richtig, sonst eine Berichterstattung aus,
kaum, also während der Entwicklung. Es gibt natürlich immer über ein Release dann eine Berichterstattung, aber das ähm.
Ja, ich meine, man kommt halt nicht mit als Redakteur. Also, du kannst, du musst ja eigentlich einen Live-Chat machen, um letztendlich über so ein Projekt zu berichten, was halt grad da Sache ist,
Und da bin ich gespannt, wie es weitergeht. Wobei ich auch sagen muss, dass wir eigentlich bisher ganz gut weggekommen sind.
Bin da auch zufrieden, also klar, es gibt hier und da Sachen,
da würde ich auch einfach mal behaupten mich aus dem Fenster zu lehnen da wurden wir einfach falsch verstanden. Also wenn halt zum Beispiel gesagt wird, wir stellen das fertige Docersgrip zur Verfügung, dass man den Server mit einem Knopfdruck ausführen kann und den uns zu Hause aus dem Rechner am Laufen hat.
Ja, dann sind da halt äh ist da kein ausgefeiltes äh Permission Management mit drin. Äh ja, da steht dann halt tatsächlich direkt auf der Wetme Seite, mit welchem Passwort man sich einloggen kann,
aber das ist dann halt am Ende auch, weil's so gewollt ist. Und das ist natürlich nicht, wie wir's in der Praxis depleune. Also,
auf dein Produktivsystem führt halt keiner Doccer One aus und lässt die Konsole offener mit der Server nicht beenden wird.
Das ist vielleicht auch ein Punkt, wo bei uns das Open Sowas so ein bisschen an die Grenzen kommt. Ähm wir haben öffentlich nicht dokumentiert, wie wir das production Setup laufen lassen. Also das ist halt ähm
unter Verschluss. Äh das kann man drüber nachdenken, ob das gut so ist oder ob das nicht gut ist, aber es ist gerade halt einfach so.
Das heißt, alles, was wir halt auf dem Gitarp haben, ist dafür da eine eigene sich selbst zu erstellen und dann halt die Software anzugucken. Was wir nicht machen, aktuell ist halt ein offenes ähm,
Oriting letztendlich von ähm dem Betrieb unserer Infrastruktur.
Aber es wäre vielleicht etwas, worüber nochmal nachdenken könnte, ob das leistbar, erforderlich ist und wie, wenn man dazukommt, das so machen zu wollen, äh das dann auch durchführen konnte.
Wir sind noch nicht bei hundert Prozent.
Ja. Na gut, die Forderung war ja.
Dann verweise ich an der Stelle einfach mal auf ihr Schuh Nummer zweihundertzweiundzwanzig, für die bessere spätere Nachverfolgbarkeit im.
Schon drin. Alles klar, kommt in die Shownotes nach Datenjournalismus, gründen wir jetzt hier den Coach Journalismus, da wird äh live direkt aus dem Inditor berichtet. Ja.
Das wäre lustig, irgendwie so. Ja, was haben wir denn heute für Comics? Ah, hier zehn Stück in der Gesundheitsapp. Und zwanzig jetzt beim neuen Personalausweis.
Sieben davon für den Linter.
Zehn neue Backs, die dich stauen lassen werden, beim fünften musst du weinen.
Malte, Thomas, vielen, vielen Dank
für die Ausführung hier zur Corona One-App. Jetzt haben wir hier zweieinhalb Stunden gequatscht. Das scheint hier so ein bisschen die Standardlänge äh zu sein für diesen Themenblock
Ja, ich äh hoffe, das konnte euch alles ein bisschen näher heranführen an äh dieses Projekt und was jetzt hier alles so passiert ist
Ich werde natürlich bei UKW noch weiter dranbleiben und äh das weitere beobachten, wie sich das alles entwickelt, aber für heute ist dann erstmal Schluss. Jetzt könnt ihr mal die App runterladen, mal selber mal
wie toll die User-Experience da ist. Wie gesagt, als Spiel enttäuscht die App ein bisschen, aber es könnte durchaus sein.
Dass wir damit unsere Situation etwas verbessert bekommen. Und das ist es ja schon mal wert. Bis dahin sage ich tschüss und bis bald.